[Music]
yes sir yes sir
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah what's going on what's
going on
there's what's going on i appreciate
that bro christopher what's going on
yeah man just thank you for the
moderation you know we got a
lord lars i don't know man i think you
might be
beyond probation bro you spamming the
chat every week
oh [ __ ] of design yo thank you for the
tweet man
good evening from germany i saw the
tweet means a lot
you know i like that grandma likes the
lord so we gonna keep it keep it right
for you man so i appreciate you in here
we'll be starting up in the field and uh
shout out to us again we got my man
frodo up in there everybody's chilling
you know what i'm saying so we're just
waiting i got an addict in here talk to
people right quick
hello there we go very very very on
point with his hello
well you know king should be in here
barge in the room so doing what he do
and then from there we'll wait for us
off and i'll get this thing started
you know what i'm saying i had you
laughing
yeah yo frodo i'm sorry fortnite i'm
sorry bro i'm sorry i had to do it man
sir
ignoring right now a rad man you know
how we do it baby
you know he's not a lot of games so when
i seen it it had to go down anyway
see y'all in a minute and uh dizzy good
looking out for the moderation brother
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right and we are
live welcome to the iron launch podcast
and the lords of gaming.net episode
number 173
there's another glorious sunday we're
back at the round table on the lord's
date
and today we've got joseph stanton
returning to halo
call of duty next gen upgrade confusion
ratchet and clank demo
and 4k switch pro to discuss so we gonna
get right into it
so let's introduce the four horsemen of
gaming those original lords of the realm
here at the round table
my co-host with the colemos my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror
lord of reviews and the how of the young
wolf
my man lord addict how we doing sir
doing pretty good
you know a little tired a little tired
but uh but i'll get through it man i'll
get through
no doubt we got it where are you yeah
where are you that is a good question
where are you i can't tell you what to
see what the hell
happened zachary for breaking your
camera
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh i've been playing wasteland three man
i've been playing a lot of wasteland
three actually i think i've played
more wasteland than i've played any
other game this year
wow i'm going to play it today um
i would say i have about 70 80 hours in
this game
um okay okay moving out here moving and
grooving
so so far like definitely feeling like
it's that thing
it's it's my game of the year
final fantasy prior you had final
fantasy and then you switched it to
uh ghost sushima so now wasteland 3
has the title sir that's cause like
these type of games i
i just enjoy them more like i love
and i see they combine the two aspects
of games i love that
like i really enjoy the uh the x-com
games you know you're not a prisoner of
the moment
you sound like you flip-flopped all over
you know what it is you got it you got
to watch it
you're right but with adam you got to
wait until he get to the end
because if the ending is bad he'll throw
his whole review in the book
you're calling everything like
there's no question i thought he was
time-free
he's calling all everybody bae though
[Music]
chat salute lord's in chat y'all better
put some respect lord snap those on
lords now those name that brother
grinding salute he's out here giving us
a lot of iop first looks
he's killing it right now shane a couple
other games so you know also undead as
well so salute to him what else we got
well we have game over brian i like that
name
king i found mario behind the chat
already i didn't even look let me see
[Laughter]
he's gonna end up buying one that walks
and not tell us
i don't keep the stream up anymore
all day every day yeah i just enjoy like
you know
i really enjoy the xcom style games but
i've never been able to play an
x-com style game with like the
like a hardcore rpg element this
the the best way to describe this game
is it's pretty much the outer worlds and
the old fallouts
with with xcom
bro that's what's up man can't front
that's what's up and
of course we have our most technical
game lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus mr offline
profile illuminati and lord patreon of
the iron bank
my man lord sovereign how we doing sir
doing fantastic gentlemen
good afternoon how much this is the last
time i say good afternoon yeah we have
one more week sir
you still have one week
this about to happen this year man i'm
about to just show up at one regardless
it's like the broadcast started two
hours ago
not for me they gonna show up
[Laughter]
hey let's get this judge real quick
sweetie smith with the five dollar super
chat
lord kag was absolutely fantastic on
unlocked iop
is on the rise yes we have doubled up
let's bend the knees
we really gotta like like you know
appreciate babe
not only was cognito on unlocked the
next day
what something wrong fire team chat
oh i thought you said something was
wrong
i'm immediately listening to fire team
yeah i i i
like i i like fire team chat but i don't
really listen to destiny podcasts like
that
but i had to go with them watch that
well you know
um i don't really watch fire team chat
right
because i'm um um you know it's red or
blue you know
i'm i'm loyal you know you know
but i had to go
and i had to check out and see what the
flavor was over there on that
on that side of the street you know i
was like yo
it's nice i said but it's something
missing
there's something missing and it was
introducing
oh yeah i said you know
somebody told me the other day
that they wait for your introductions
with baited breath
wow wow and they said
they stop what they're doing to hear it
from beginning to end
because no two are the same
and you can tell you thoroughly enjoyed
writing it
you did your research with it and you
worked hard
and you're giving individuals a
fingerprint
when they come on the show thank you
because it's unique to them
mm-hmm i appreciate it but i love i love
doing it i mean
when you get to my phone and i want to
point out
that the lords never have
oh no no no no you no no no no
no you guys got one i never never
got one i do young wolf for you i threw
the sword on you cool
all right here we go
our community well online yes he did to
the fullest um so real quick oh one more
regulator 951
2 super chat good morning to you lords
cox intros are
always fire that is for thank you so
real quick
i don't know this week you might have to
call me captain game pastors oh
i was i was in there yeah i was rocking
oh my god
took over for kings for you
for sure for sure so i gotta go with
attic man like wasteland three
i got in there and i was just
complaining a little bit about the fact
that it doesn't have
uh play anywhere so i started on the
console and i'm like i cannot play this
type of game on this big tv
let me switch over to the pc so i'm
thinking my progress is going over
no not at all i had to start over but
that it's fine it's fine because it's a
great game
um and you know me i never traditionally
been that rts guy
but like adding said mixing that rtx rts
with a hardcore crpg to the extent
they've done it with this game
that is like leaps and bounds over what
what wasteland 2 was
um yo yo can the entry point be straight
to
wasteland 3 if you didn't play the other
two absolutely absolutely yeah
you don't even and like i've never i you
don't even need context really i dabble
with a little bit in the second one but
i never really sat down and played a
whole lot of it
yeah because the gameplay just outdated
yeah
like it felt kind of old yeah so but
like
i can't say since i never played those
games to the fullest that
there's a there's probably easter eggs
in this game that reference those games
right but
it's just like to me i've never
once thought you know what what are they
talking about because
they don't really make you feel like you
have to know what's going on
and i i also one thing about this game
again like i've always said
this is the game that should be getting
a lot it's getting a lot of praise right
but because of the perspective because
of the crpg roots it's not going to get
the love that it
deserves it's not going to happen it's
just not going to happen and literally
if you shift the camera behind
your player character are you implied
that just states that i really do feel
like look no one's saying that you know
the games that sony doesn't make are
amazing because they are yeah but it's
like i am i am really getting tired of
this no
notion that like the industry has right
now that the only way to make games is
sony's
like and i i'm getting tired until they
fall on their face they're gonna we're
gonna keep
continuing i mean like i've always just
aesthetically to somebody who doesn't
know anything about it you look at a
sony first party game like oh that looks
pretty
let me see let me let me go let me see
how i shop for games
when i go to pax and e3 and stuff like
that for my interviews
and see what's visually pleasing to me
what pops with my eyes and i say well
you know what
they never heard about this and they
need to know about this looks amazing
you find a lot of gems for a lot of gems
the visual whatever captures you first
and we're
all graphic cards i don't care what
anybody say actually we're all graphic
stars
so whatever pops visually for you you
got to rock with that and and if sony
mastered it and they understood that
formula and they're controlling that
formula
good god and you know i was talking to
um
you know shout out to oh no alex and uh
them over at press start
yeah so i i was talking to him and i was
like you know what i was like if you
want to get technical
like back in the day man it used to be
that bioware
exile obsidian bethesda those were the
rpg makers like you're the godfathers of
this
of this genre and microsoft owns two out
of four of them like
crazy so that's fantastic no actually i
played
them tell me why as well oh i hear good
things i hear yo i'll tell you
like let's get these two real quick
because i don't know if you got the copy
paste from yeah i got them um clutch man
with the final super chat ready for the
feel good podcast of the week
that barbershop game talk have a good
full guy two months till the next it is
like a barbershoot
barbershop gossip right here
then we got sifu poetic x initiative
with the five dollar super chat
phil please get in exile off the unity
engine yeah
the thing is that if microsoft because
you know i will say
that this game is a quality game i love
this game but
i will you know acknowledge games like
ghost games like final fantasy there are
better games just this kind of game is
more for me but right
divinity's more on track with this game
and when you play divinity that's an
attractive looking game yeah you know
what then i got that game to when i
didn't play so divinity originally
two yeah two especially to like the
animations when you do spells and stuff
on that game
you're just like yo they they they they
did they stuff
amazing green mason gifted me that game
and you still haven't
got it no well you know what it is a lot
of times uh
people like they don't know what you're
where you're doing right right so at
that time a bunch of games come out in
game pass and i'm playing these games in
game pass
and from the kindness of his heart he
sends a game to me gosh like yo
i played this game this game is nice i
need you to check it out you know we do
that with each other from time to time
and i said okay cool and then when you
said it right now i was like oh man i
didn't get it
you know so you know let me dive deep
into that you know
yeah we got hold on one second i think
we got two yeah we got two
we have uh jw's a shill with the five
dollar super
i want my 36x pre-order and i want it
now i will shove it by old ladies and
step off step on babies damn
wow this baby's gonna catch this
yeah like i said tell me why um dope not
has progressively
uh been sort of honing their craft in
terms of storytelling in terms of
realistic uh
sort of uh conversation and interactions
between characters they've continued to
get better at that
um i just i want them to take it to the
next step get
you know get a graphics engine that
that's something like
like an until dawn or something like
that bring you up to that level
absolutely
um but in terms of the storytelling yeah
they'll get there yeah they're there
but also i gotta plug the team i gotta
plug the home team shout out the
lordsgamer.net with that tremendous
review we're gonna talk about that even
further
more but i believe it was undead who did
um which calls it don't tell me
tell me why tell me why questions so is
that in the uh life of strange universe
yes
it is okay shout out to the home team
lord's game down that up there killing
it so that's been it pretty much it
song
i'm just gonna say like you know shout
out to laura king like
this has been a good year for game pass
like
if you think about it wasteland 3 is on
there you know
uh tell me why we we were we were making
fun until we walked away
we weren't really making fun of it we
were just we
we was making jokes out of the name on
everything man
you know if you guys haven't seen that
reaction when we reacted to that uh
whatever that jeff's event was called
go go watch it man because we me and
keith we're saying
somebody in the comments said my
laughter was
forced yeah oh he was in here early up
here spamming the chat you know what i
do
you mad with us
one right here because bro that was pure
comedy you don't know how do we do back
in the day like
y'all thought you had one like you
really thought
and it's so funny when you think
somebody going off for the finger roll
like patrick hewitt
and they boof it like
and you know what's funny i went back
and i watched it after i got to work
man how is this man keith gonna downplay
everything wrenching
oh he was not failing some sony dude was
out here pounding his chest for no
reason
but you know i
look the contrast look really high yeah
it's all over the place right now yeah
we all know what's going on
i try to be nice because i want them to
process on time
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka the access gamer
the lord of combat sports king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
ooh beloved little kid how are we doing
sir
yo shout out to the pbc yo
last night was good i had the human
sponge angulo
fight and he do what he does best soak
up punches
stay to the end and it's it's time for
you
to to hang it up brother like your best
days was in that detention center
damn it's over when they held them they
held him for over a year some change and
he aged like bad cheese
it's done son hang it up
train kids do something to generate
income
um but brother if you take another punch
i'm going to jump in and stop that fight
some people some people are just way
better teachers than the other be doing
the
he got that real circle around him to be
like look you need to probably
somebody need to tell him again but
also we had uh estee lauder
um fight yesterday and he cruised to
a unanimous decision it was a beautiful
fight
um i'm seeing how pbc is doing the
boxing
and you know with the fake crowd there's
no crowd yeah
i like how the zone does it because they
do it in some some
billionaires backyard
and it looks like a real spectacle um
but
you know we're trying to figure out and
navigate through this
weird world that everybody has to
co-exist in
and i'm watching basketball it looks
like a rec center
it um i don't know what football is
going to look like
um i think it's most likely and yeah
it's going to be different different
times i didn't get the chance to see
baseball
um so um you know just have to visually
is striking at first because you you
know what you used to
used to right exactly right it's about
getting used to new stuff
but um neon the best man
whoa neon abyss
really i'm a huge let me turn that off i
don't even know how you
can how are you still alive
it's like time out bro like what how are
you alive
um i i'm gonna tell you right now
i really if it wasn't for game pass and
i keep you know
y'all dudes think i'm um a cat for this
thing right this this game pass when
netflix first came out
we always wanted something that was
better than showtime
better than hbo because hbo
and showtime always lean to the same
formulas right
just like sony over the shoulder
story driven right splash
next one they go see that's the bro
yeah but you know like you got the
sopranos right right you can't front
they got
they got that and while while netflix
was gaining its legs
they kept calling it crap filler filler
i got phillip
and it got to the point where netflix
is doing feature films
that are incredible to watch
and they diversity is insane
so i take that over the game pass and
the diversity in the games that i'm
playing that have
i normally wouldn't play and i'm happy
that we go to pax
because i get to see these games in
their infancy yeah for sure for sure
and then i look over and say oh snap we
we covered this game
let me play it now as it's completed
and it turns out to be exactly what i
thought it was a banger
that nobody was going to give time to
but through game pass you get that
light because you get a chance to try
everything so i'm telling you right now
out of all the games that i have i keep
finding myself at neon abyss
that knee on the base okay it's probably
my indie game of the year wow
probably my indie game of the year it
has to be because
the level of addiction is higher
than uh dead cells wow
soft we we can go out of this i mean i
haven't played it yet so
but i mean that's to say that that means
something because dead cells is like
it's cracked it really is correct that's
what's up so it's been pretty much
that for the most part okay yeah that
you know that's it and then you know
saturday
uh uh madness and stuff um me defending
against the
wild hordes of the tcl oh the tcl games
bro
but i like when people send you pictures
of them and be like king does not
approve of me
i love it you started a video i sent you
of old boy
and every time he talked about a cheap
tv
any show anything else to show tcl
comprehensive review on on why they're
not the best in quality in hd i'm like
the funny thing is if you think about
tcl isn't the bottom rung like they're
going this
[Music]
himself the shinobi lord cognito
spreading that realness and around the
ilp
not telling what you want to hear but
what you need to hear
shout out
get yourself off king roll to the right
for a second i don't know what he wants
i guess he wants to see mario
it's got to be here it's got to be mario
it's got to remember all right so we
caught up
apologies yes go ahead that's my word
so if you want me to roll it right
here but your salute to everybody man in
the community what a week it was just
tremendous absolutely the love man it
was
overwhelming and um to get you know
selected and chosen
by my peers to to be on like an ign
unlocked and
obviously to follow up with the five
team chat truly truly humbling it was
just dope it was just dope to see
everybody one of the things i was most
proud of i seen people
support the move that necessarily don't
talk to each other
but we're happy that the lord's got
representation up there you know what
i'm saying
so for me that means a lot because i
know we're unifying and we're trying to
you know saying bring this thing
together at the end of the day it's
gaming we all know everybody got their
little favorite
and all that but at the end of the day
it's gaming that's the unifier
so it made me extremely proud it was it
was cool to throw the crest stuff
in there you know i said get up in the
spotlight but yeah shout out to that man
shout out to ign for all for doing that
shout out to
me i want to shout a couple names too
heated heavy man he eat it heavy you
you're responsible for a lot of things
man so i want to salute you brother
you know i mean you definitely put the
stuff in the air neo game spark you know
what i'm saying
like for sure a lot of people put the
energy up in the air
and you know from listen you king
addicts uh
you know from where we from those
opportunities don't happen you know what
i'm saying like those
especially you know i'm saying people
like us so to see it it felt good it
felt different you know what i'm saying
it just hit different you know what i'm
saying so salute to everybody to the
cause was going by too
and um but uh yeah man so after that i
wanted to
um shout out a couple other people um i
see my bro uh ivanta's last word
fire team shout outs up in the building
salute you know what i'm saying so
that was love to get the love there and
um yeah man it was it was a fun week it
was a full week man it's
true also it was a huge week for uh
logicgaming.net
uh with undead and open critics yes
um yes i want to shout them out too the
whole editorial team
like i said super proud lord let's throw
that
up in there right quick that lords of
gaming.net
you know what i'm saying like finally
approve open critics so our reviews and
again it's a testament to the team i
want to shout out lord josh reading
lloyd lord dizzy you know the hyatt all
the editorial staff
rage virus lord bachman everybody you
know how everybody because at the end of
the day
to be recognized by your peers
professionally that
your bodies of work when it comes to
reviews are certified and we're going to
use that as an aggregate
as a small site we've only been around
for a year y'all you know what i'm
saying like
we're only one years old like that is
tremendous so salute to the whole team
yo like i said it's a very emotional
week for me like super proud
made your boy shed a tear that love was
crazy man i tried to respond to each and
every comment
so and then salute to my brothers man
y'all was holding me down yeah i was
rapping i was retweeting
it was love man like i said geek dream
come true week i tell you like i was
sitting there
like you know when you you're watching
something just cheesing
and you and you catch yourself cheesing
out yo
my wife looked at me like what are you
smiling i'm like
look look at this and she's like okay
fine i see i i see
but you had to explain it and i was like
this is
the number one xbox podcast on the
planet
yeah this is the most watched xbox
podcast on planet and she was like oh
okay yeah okay so when we're moving
downtown
i had to do the same thing it was love
definitely definitely better like i said
we'll hopefully see more of that in the
future
and stuff like that oh shout out though
was it phantom kraken we got that
we got luke laura first of all we got
proud of iop
several times over thank you my brother
thank you thank you
skipping ghost fandom cracking with the
dude super chat congratulations to you
guys and the lords of gaming
thank you sir no much love much love but
yeah besides that not been much gaming
because i haven't been on everybody else
i mean oh they mad with me kay
what yo
i see that you know obviously i'm just
saying you're like this man
i'm gonna tell you right now oh
something and you know what before we
get on the podcast
you ain't supposed to be you ain't
supposed to be talking about that he's
getting upset that he's downloading the
client
on his on his pc and i'm just thinking
myself
you're going to play that for like 10
minutes and then especially when the
event's over he ain't going to last
i've been known for a specific
especially simple server related stuff
let's go over them other things just
like
for for something minor like yep needed
to have it i forgot what it was
i can't i wouldn't give you a fraud
alert you okay that's true to your
nature
when i saw it i said exactly
you know it's funny too you know it took
that for them to get you
and do you know how many millions of
views it was that clicked on that skin
you know how uh you know how you the
first thing i thought when i saw that
this is one of those scenarios like a
year from now cognito goes on fourth i
forgot i bought that
no he won't he will never forget silver
third foot
was on fortnite i haven't been let me
i've been so disrespectful to this
franchise
i called them the bumble rapper i called
you
even pubg like i've been on my square
for however long they've been out
i've looked on their square and all it
took was
my main silver server and i'm like oh
and that then your kick they got the
hostage situation
you don't get it by tomorrow it's gone
i'm like
oh it was a
like you said i'm a huge surfer fanboy
he's rarely
in any marvel games or either it's a
secret character for the most part he's
always left out
so when i see it and then they got the
galactus join and i'm like oh this
pow and then they got the board when you
come i'm like oh
man they got me sir they got me it was
i knew it i was like i'm just going to
put it out there last night
i said exactly that's exactly what i
said exactly
you know what's funny that i love about
iop man every time a new
battle royale comes out out of nowhere i
gotta sit here and defend a game i don't
like called fortnite like man you guys
call every time one of these games come
out fortnite's done
fortnight's done there's there's no way
remember when uh wooden call of duty
it was apex it was wait no we did it for
both
i capped so hard for both of those games
they got them
i remember i was like man you got you
guys are you guys are tripping no
man you don't know is it like oh what do
they do
they'll oh so people are doing so that's
cute that's cute hit up marvel hit up
marvel yo what they did
they put a black screen and took all
these other dude's views
for like two days it took everybody's
views
let me let me get this to attack
get over that name i saw it king i guess
they're they're they're
riffing on your addiction i believe okay
you said sorry
listen if you want to pay just to try to
correct me you're full
congratulations and support to the iop i
remember my first time listening
and y'all have only gotten better i
raised my glass the master of the day
thank you thank you thank you thank you
we better need bro
and we have sleepy goblin with the two
dollar super with the five dollars for
the chat
stayed home sick just came in and the
first thing i hear is king with more
tia tcl slander
today my sleepy goblin i just i lowkey
wanted to just get off and go to bed
i must snap you with a panel of mini
leds sir sleepy time
i i hear all of that they in the bushes
glad to catch the lords hit that like
button return your tcl
absolutely we have jean-marc luigi
chat they got the ps5 fire extinguisher
bundle edition
that's messy very messy very messy there
we go
almost 4 000 subs let's go family hit
that like button
thank you brother
he just hit like 8k subs man yeah yeah
brother i want you to go to his channel
i want you to like follow and subscribe
i want you to go to his twitter i want
you to like follow and subscribe
and this dude has been a positive beacon
for the playstation
uh community uh a lot of those dudes
just they're severely toxic and suffer
from
a severe case of stuff that's going on
in here
um you're not gonna get to correct me
bro
you're not gonna do it bro but um
yeah but uh big cloud he's that guy man
for real
so we all caught up yeah we're good oh
no oh shout out i gotta see someone in
the chat i got
shout out to hazard oil gaming this
man's meme game
is crazy he's crazy he's super lit with
the men shout out the woman
he threw you with the hat yeah
team chat shout out to how they go for
being better like uh it's been you know
he was in an accident and he was not
well
oh man it's fantastic to see you back
and do it best brother he got me out
there with the derby with the gates of
joy on fire team
then he said ig i'm making moves and he
got the the meme with the money going
under the table
and then yeah i was like oh
man like
[Music]
did you convert did you bend the knee
i don't know listen so we gotta get
shout out to hazelnut he'd be in his bag
you know say shout out to everybody with
that
i want to shout out xbox news reddit
y'all get your
xbox news out there they're moving and
shaking out there man so again
xbox dudes read it you get the latest
and greatest of what's going on please
check them out
very supportive of what they got going
on and also on a side note please y'all
send some love to jay fonzarelli
he's really going through a tough
situation right now i'm not going to put
the details of his business out there
but yo check on my brother you know i
mean he's going through a lot he
really could use the support the
grounded gamer
jay fosurelli i know what it is he's
been here before rdx podcast
all of them but yeah definitely hit him
up check on him make sure he's okay
he's going through a lot of you just try
to keep his spirits up today so
that's what i got anybody got anything
before we get into the polling
[Laughter]
with the latest reveals at dc fandom of
suicide squad and gotham knights
what has you most excited for release
the winner of our three-way iop poll at
63
was the gotham knights post batman crew
for the win
coming in at second place at 23 percent
was i don't care
stop these games as a service superhero
game
and then last place close 14 with
suicide squad team-up shooter to kill
the justice league
shout out to all the lords who
participated lord king do you agree with
the gotham knights as the
more exciting dc fandom game
um is the only one that would truly
stand out um
who would you like to say suicide squad
trailer yes it was it was a cgi joint
they didn't come in until like
2022 or something of course
a game that you see that's about to show
up that's in the same vein of the batman
that you've been begging for
for for the past five six years and it
happens to have four playable characters
come on man of course just and it came
out of the blue and dudes was like oh my
god
you get a chance but is batman really
dead
four people how come you can only play
shout out to you clowns
that got a reason to complain for
everything like it's not like they
haven't played him back with batman like
in four games or five games
but see sovereign it's just the fact
that they said it's four characters how
come we can't play four people carl up
yeah
man get out of here
would not be a proper sunday without the
iop in effect
salute salute salute so we got all last
we gonna get into this stuff man we got
a lot to talk about let's get it
percolating um yeah so joseph
statten y'all joseph stanton the
legendary joseph stan
has returned one of the most renowned
figures from the halo
universe he basically started his career
with bungie did a bunch of the original
series
and then um yeah he kind of left it i
think around 2013
and now has um rejoined microsoft 343
and um he's going to be working to help
them i guess you know with the
with the narrative aspect but also to a
leadership role and then besides
that it's also um pierre heights i don't
know if i pronounce his name correctly
another senior leader with 343 to focus
on halo infinite
and serve as a project lead for its free
to play experience so it looks like
again
we're gonna get the uh on the story base
the campaign side we'll get joseph
you know on the multiplayer side we'll
get pierre and it says the new project
leads plural will work with studio head
chris lee
and report to bonnie ross so it's a big
kind of a shake-up and it's what kind of
hit the uh the interwebs
so i just want to bring this to the
realm you know with this information
how we feeling we we all all know about
the controversy that is halo infinite
so let's get lord addict or resident
halo uh
lore person you know what are you
feeling man do you think this is the
right move do you think this is
insignificant where are you
at with joseph staton i think if
anything that the biggest thing that
this shows
yeah it's it's it's looking bad over
there man like i
i feel like you know things are worse at
three i know i'm about to say this
things look like it's worse at 343 than
we thought
well you know uh to to me i know i made
a video
made a lot of people mad but you know
i don't think 2021 is cutting it man
i think this game might be 2022 maybe
even the beginning of 2023
like because to me you don't bring
in key factors like this
to a project almost done why stop
smoking
you you bring people like this into a
project
would you you pretty low-key toss the
whole project out
like like you know i don't i think
they're going to savage whatever they
can but i do think they're remaking halo
infinite i don't think it's coming up
all right so let me ask you this so you
think because i mean we'd have to admit
at this stage of the project
the narrative aspect we would assume is
is done done
so my question to you addict is do you
think
that he's dead so in your opinion you
think he's there
to today they're going to shake things
up completely
that's the truth so you don't think that
he's there to kind of like almost
get the ball over the goal line so to
speak
just part of me like why would he be
there to hit the ball of the goat like
to me he never would have been called if
craig wouldn't have been lit
so so it's just like at this point they
they had to choose between
their brand or they i mean they've
already
i think what happened is once they
delayed the game out of the xbox series
x's uh launch tower they're like okay
like people clearly still care about the
halo brand
um we need to get people in there and we
need to get this
ship on the right course so then they
get him for the single player they get
the other dude for the multiplayer
and to me it could could it be just
something that they do
to finish up the development cycle of
halo infinite
right so and they're permanently there
going here on out
maybe but to me they they would be in
closer to halo infinite in in game like
the fact that they didn't even give us a
window when this game's coming up they
just said
is delayed and definitely 20 21's when
it comes infinite
coming in he's coming in hot fight
didn't they bring in joseph staton at
the end of crackdown 3 to help with the
narrative
why you got to drop that and leave
would you like about the attic i mean do
i really have to speak on crackdown
three i mean i i think the game speaks
enough for itself
like i thought the game was uh fantastic
it was good but the thing is is you know
it
it was a game that had a lot of
responsibility that could never have
lived up to it
it was supposed to be a launch title to
the series that to the xbox one x
so you know i do think that there is
some truth in what he's saying i don't
think it's as serious as crackdown
the difference between crackdown and the
the difference between
the reason why let me finish no no i'm
gonna tell you the reason why i
i believe so you can say whatever you
want to say
they showed a demo of a engine
and the marketing team ran with that
crap right
they threw a self under the damn bus
this joint
is as serious because they had a demo
of an actual game that is not no demo of
no
no of engine or something that they they
no fabrication of something that they
hope to put inside some game
no this was the game
this is it we're here so now that we're
here and like you said
craig is lit this is you said this
and it is true so what
you're going to say next is that okay
it's not as bad as that situation
because it can never live up to this
this is what it is
you know crackdown is not halo by any
stretch of the imagination
so crackdown was always going to be a
little sideshow little game on the side
that people play there was playstation
dudes that were throwing
extra heat on top of that okay
xbox dudes was like what are you talking
about crackdown that's some just a
little fun joint that they always
bundle halo with to sell it it
never sold on its own it was never its
own thing right
so like i understand why you upset
because i watched your video
so i sorry to jump into your joint right
now because i know you were
you going i watched your video okay so i
got yeah
for your for your copy because i know he
muted his mic right now yeah
you're doing his best baby i i let you
finish well i appreciate it
firing at the end of the day i think
it's worse in certain scenarios because
it's not a crackdown it's a halo but i
do think the reason crackdown was in the
position it was
was because they taunted technology that
they didn't even know they could do it
and i i think that's what the issue was
with on crackdown because
crackdown single player wasn't that bad
it was actually a pretty fun experience
it's just it's just then they have to
they didn't have the rights to detect no
more it's a weird scenario
just a bunch of nonsense regardless even
what happened behind closed doors
they pretty much at the beginning of
that showed you the
perfect blt this is what we're trying to
sell you trying to see this amazing blt
and when you get into a peanut butter
and jelly sandwich
and i think that just rubs people the
wrong way they're like look like
yo did you see how pissed he played
you know
chat the problem with crackdown 3 was
that epic bought the cloud giant
cloud engine uh and their tech mid
development of the game
they lost them and had to figure out
that uh the game was healthy
shout out to the bullying somebody took
their ball and went home and left
them left them hanging dude it is what
it is so just
let me ask you this i'll be at it in
reference to okay so
i got your theory you you feel this
thing maybe really re-scrap so
do you think it was the right move do
you yes
okay so you you agree 100 no i don't
mind them delaying it they could delay
this game to 2024.
i wouldn't care the problem with that is
that the longer you delay it let's say
it comes out this year
the expectations if it comes out this
year is going to be lower if it comes
out a year
for a year and a half from now two years
from now the longer this game keeps
getting delayed
that's why they didn't give it a date
because they don't even know what's
gonna happen right now
right but the longer this game keeps
getting delayed the worse it will be
when it comes out because it will build
a better expectation a bit more hype
so people are sitting there like you
expect more from a game that's been
delayed multiple times because you feel
like the product is supposed to be
better
i agree with that part i agree with that
part no doubt lord
sob joseph stanton and then pierre
to handle the uh multiplayer like what
what's your thought process on these
moves
i do think that it's it's a lot greater
than they
that they are they're not going to let
on dude they're not groomed this is the
domain
yeah i mean they're not going to ever
let out don't give us something to be
doing about
i look at david's background and all i
think about is putting on some black air
forces to see how much i could get
for all of them
[Laughter]
how much you can get
you sell all those statues man you can
buy a house oh yeah
you're buying a crib with them um yo so
look at bg man again i want to salute
him
he had a big game yeah
man look it's good to see hey bg hit me
up on twitter
moving yeah good good to see dudes
moving it's good to see representation
man and bg
he's one of the i call him the young og
he's been doing it for a minute one of
the top podcasts in the game
and when he does his solo content he's
still out there moving and shaking so
salute to the guy you already know what
it is you don't say it and appreciate
the support about you show me some love
as well so you already know but um yes
you want to get the rest of super chats
man
pixel bit g with the final super chat
people how whack xbox be
they and killer instinct devs mid
development what type of clowns allow
that
need to do better like now oh
all right let's get to it let's get to
it what you're feeling uh
when you bring in guys like that these
are two guys that are
uh that are used to creating a a
an idea like something from the ground
up right
they aren't that's they had not
necessarily known as closers right this
is not like you know leslie benzies and
rockstar like give me the bands i don't
need nothing
[Music]
he had a repetition for closing getting
things right these are guys that that
create things from the ground up
and build them um you know stanton was
on halo one two and three
obviously it was very well received very
well received so when you bring in a guy
like that
and again i don't i don't know him i
don't necessarily know his style of
of of managing and whatnot but
oftentimes guys that work in that
fashion
find it difficult to come into a
situation where what they're saying is
that they're not
displacing anyone he's coming in to
support the people that are there
already
right um which i don't necessarily
believe that's a very nice pr
things that wait what do you think's off
i think he's coming he's coming in there
to crack the whip
and whatever is broken in terms of
narrative and does not fit
i think is going to get rejiggered so
they're going to like me today
i just don't think you know there was a
lot from the beginning when they
when they announced when they announced
the the delay i was like this ain't
this ain't a three-month delay i'm
saying holiday at the very least 2021.
then i saw some things like when the
xbox pre-order pages sort of went up
right people said it was mistakes or
whatever but it said
holiday 2021 right right for whatever
reason whether it's placeholder whatever
the case may be
this to me adds even more credence to
that and maybe like alex said even
further out
because you don't bring in guys like
this
to just see things across the finish
line the
guys that are going to look at that
entire narrative they're going to be the
finish line
and see if it gets let me ask you this
though i got to ask both of you all this
because you guys are making some solid
color points i love the discussions
going
what about to the to the point we know
that the series x right now is lacking
that kill it you know
exclusive first part exclusive and this
was supposed to be tied and synonymous
with with the ex
halo infinite now you're talking
potentially
2021 no no big first party exclusive
they lost one
right and then my my thing is also what
about the fiscal year do don't you think
they would like to get this thing out
to say hey we still have something look
at this engagement i mean regardless of
however halo hit when it dropped it do
what it do
numbers wise we can say we won about
halo 5
right i could say it's mediocre but when
you look at the investment aspect when
you look at
the return like they did what it did the
rec packs the engagement stuff so
you don't think there's any pressure on
them maybe to still get it out in 2021
but this is the thing halo 5 regardless
of why you felt about it
was a finished polished experience it
was polished it was just whatever you
feel about it you don't like it or not
it was finished and
polished the indication i get from this
is that it's not finished it's not
anywhere near as polished i didn't know
it wasn't polished
yeah to me halo infinite seems to be in
a different
state than than halo 5 was
what about what about i hate the country
what about completion
don't you think at this stage of the
game
isn't that game done narratively
isn't it like it should be which is why
bringing in somebody like joseph stanton
is is great but worrisome because again
he's a dude that's used to be like from
the beginning you take the reins and you
craft this world right
and if there's anybody who's going to be
in on the ground floor of crafting
something
halo related is a joseph stanton you're
telling him now
i need you to come in and supervise
these dudes and and just
and see you know
it does not make a lot of sense to me
bro it doesn't make a lot of sense to me
in terms of like what what they're being
honest about i don't think they're being
honest about his level of involvement
and
the changes that he's going to be making
there you think they would last point
you think they're willing to eat that
develop what's this game better
development fine
this ain't cheap so i'm here to extend
this game to another two more years
and all that investment they already
made it the sacrificial lamb right
why why why if that was the case then
don't even delay it and put it out there
and let it be what it is
if you're gonna delay it delay it as
long as it needs to be to be a quality
product now however long that is right
and even if you
you weren't completely honest about that
up front now it's delayed you haven't
put a date on it yet
just get the product out that you want
to get out right
don't i don't care how long it takes at
this point now like just i'm sorry i
didn't get his balls off and did uh
super chats
i think that this could even be
something as simple as
what we've been saying bonnie ross might
be getting up out of there
like it might be one of those things
where you know she is the head of the
studio i think that she wouldn't be
removed from the studio or anything like
that
she would just be the person that that
communicates with microsoft
and whoever they put in charge over
there she's like the executive person
right
so it could be one of those lines is
like okay you know joseph go in there
you know
uh be with them the last last maybe six
months to a year they're in development
of this
get a good feel over there get a good
feel over there because once this game's
over
you that's your studio because because
they've had plenty of
time implying this supervisor role
is not supervisory and actually
that might be what it is like let's be
real here like we can't act like it's
been
it's been sunflowers and and sunshine's
over there at 343. all right
most the time has as many missteps as
is you know 343's had it's because
they're making halo that they continue
to get another shot
a lot of times you don't get this many
chat attempts
be surprised that if at some point you
see marty o'donnell
oh yeah y'all go y'all digging in craig
y'all getting that dj clue mixtape now
now y'all really digging in the crate
you gotta do it okay
all right let's get element up here with
the five dollar super chat joseph
stanton presented every halo
since the mac days he's a good guest for
infinite absolutely is
uh jd gaming with the five dollar super
chat pixel bit g
microsoft is doing better uh they lock
down a sobo for 10 years because of
flight simulator
i guess in that regard yeah yes then we
got the medic
with the five dollar super chat november
2021 halo 20th anniversary needs to be
the date for halo infinite
yeah at this point like i said like just
trying to make that
hold on to it we got gaming forte with
the ten dollar super chat
halo won't release in 2021 if it does
then you won't see any significant
changes to the look of the game joshua
and pia can
uh can't make the major changes people
expect in one year bet on 2022
2023. he was completely forte
all right so we all caught up yep king
you've been bubbling man i seen you
you're not gonna like me if you're a
halo fan you're not gonna like me you're
a three four three fan
you're not gonna like me oh there's not
a whole lot of three four three four
okay some people like them
um i happen you know i i i think
bonnie ross is a wonderful person all
right so
this is no shade to her at all nothing
we say just say to anyone
no but sometimes we're just going off
what we see
people take criticism personally right
right now criticism is for you to grow
faster all right they threw the baby out
with the bathwater
all right the moment before i held hope
i held hope
all right i held hope guys i really did
and when i saw them bring in these two
heads
they effectively cut hers off
[Music]
okay she why
they have to answer to her for what
you already were here you already
bungled it i think at that point it's
just politics
so this is exactly it all right how many
times you got to tell your kid to wash
the dishes
before you put another kid in there to
do the dishes
you do the garbage from now on since you
can't wash dishes
you got the garbage you take out the
trash
i don't want to see your face because
every time i go to drink out this glass
it's dirty um
you had your shot i feel that
it's that's it resume right it's
resonating okay
the most controversial thing that i'm
going to say right now
that slipstream engine is probably in
the bushes
because when you have a demo for unreal
engine 5
smoking yeah your slipstream engine
uh yeah i'm getting frostbite like vibes
like oh oh we say easy developer
i'm gonna tell you right now that
slipstream engine did not impress
right this is your first day out the
door
it look garbage
now you probably saying oh it does 120
frames
it does this this that in the third and
the fact that we control it
we can do whatever we want with it well
you gonna pay that fee
to the bully you're going to pay for
epic
um
all that all that buddy cop crap that
you saw in the beginning with him an old
bearded boy
that's done but i'm telling you
the next time you see halo
it's going to be what you thought it was
supposed to be wow
and it's not going to run on that
slipstream crap yeah i go in there y'all
really think it's
changing yo listen and i'ma tell you
right now
both of those heads are heads of their
perceived departments
right he's head of the the multiplayer
right he's head of the single player
right he's going to look at it and say
no this is not going to work
if you're used to building a house and
you start with the foundation
and you come with a house that the
foundation is shaky
you knock the house down and you start
over
wow he's going to start over
wow you can't call because his name is
attached to this
wow it don't seem to me i i feel we are
going but i i don't seem to me like he
still
reports i mean i know what you y'all
saying don't fall for the total but
that's what you're saying right though
that those two
cut her head off
why do you need to report to the person
that's been messing the dishes up
you got garbage let me work
you what advice did you gonna take from
somebody who bungled it and they had to
call you
i i fear that part all right listen
y'all making valid points that my only
counter is the financials number one
now she just got a check the the fact
that this
platform perceivably
could not have a accord if they do what
you guys are saying
we are literally talking 2022 2023. so
what does it say
it's already pushed out i feel you but
then you're saying
the series x will not have a first party
exclusive
most likely ready until they're like
we don't know what they working on with
the other studios right
and i believe that they can afford it i
you know what
did did my motto say uh a bad game
lasts forever oh factual factual so
halo comes out and it's not
what it's cracked up to be first of all
this guy's not coming over to put his
name on crap
he's not the full guy for nobody his
resume speaks he said the first three is
me
right i'm coming i'm coming with that
clout
right you think he's contained his stuff
for who
it's not enough money in the world for
you to take taint your reputation
right knowing that you built an offer
something good
and plus you know i want to point out
like he was still working for microsoft
so
clearly something was going on where he
didn't want to be part of 343 and
something changed
well history was bungee actually he
was responsible for doing the destiny
story
before all the changes up top and i
guess if they didn't meet their
deadlines and then they scrapped him and
i
i heard there was politics involved it
was i want to say like it's a mini
marty o'donnell situation where he
wasn't feeling situation left from
bungie
you know i'm saying state came back to
microsoft but he wasn't he had nothing
to do
with halo on 343 so he stayed separate
in his bag
doing his little projects and now being
brought in you know what i'm saying if
king infinite i want to get my balls off
no it's just the fact that you don't
bring in a heavy hitter
and have him play second fiddle to the
loser
you don't do that okay so i just want
y'all to use common sense when you look
at it
because it's presenting itself how it is
and if you're trying to save face for
anybody because
like i said before
team player right good person
you don't throw people like that under
the bus right
but at the same time if they're not
completing the task that is given
right you have to place people in pocket
that can do it
and when they do do the test you but you
have to put them there untethered
you can't put them there and have
stipulations all right so you you
you know you relay that to her and get
approval from
that's not happening i'm i don't see it
spicy by the law
i can't believe i'm actually disagreeing
with y'all
this is this i'll be listening
everything you're saying
i mean let's do this real quick at least
three people in the podcast is right
get to see what you have [ __ ] buzz up
we got uh dj birdo with the 2
super chat slip space king um i guess he
wants a sony baby
sony baby
[Laughter]
and then we have uh zero one nine four d
with the one dollar super chat please
say something brother
no doubt no doubt that's it oh wait no
we haven't right
uh jd gamer with the five dollar super
chat halo is one of the most profitable
series in
all of gaming is it it is worth more
than uncharted
god of war horizon zero dawn combined
they can't afford to screw up this ip
right oh we got 10 dislikes
y'all blaming y'all
dislike button man they doing it because
cognito ain't
being rashed i didn't even see my point
yet you know it's crazy man
it's talking to like never mind we ain't
going there
you going there there you go there oh
let me get him
let's not forget halo 8 is a platform
that is true look i get where y'all
going
everything is there's a button here
that's the thing there's definitely
but everything i do has merit and i'm
not saying that it can't happen
it's very well could happen you know
what i'm saying this is how i perceived
it when i when i heard the news first of
all
state and you already know the legendary
status the cache
you know i'm saying you know what it is
if he's getting called up to
to come in to me the game is already
done
right to me at this late day four or
five years whatever it is this stage is
getting games done
so you coming in to oversee
you being brought into oversea to me
feels like in football
y'all can't get over the goal line for
whatever reason
there's always a problem pushing this
thing over at the one yard line to score
the touchdown right
to me they just bringing this dude in to
get it over
i can't see how he is going to come in
there and say okay
everybody tear it down okay okay but
let me ask you let me let me challenge
that if the game is done
right what is there direct to finish
because i this is where i agree with
y'all there's clearly dysfunction
right this is how i look at it i'm in
the corporate world
right in my job in i.t
when we got a big project and and bing
is on the line big client
money's on the line it's all hands on
deck situation for the most part
if we prove that we are not
hitting these deadlines and we
consistently keep proving
that we are not sometimes they bring
outside people in sometimes they bring
people from other departments in
to to help right but if we consistently
keep not making these deadlines guess
what sometimes those dudes that are
brought in to help
once the project is over sometimes they
take
other people's jobs now that's the part
i agree
is a potential thing here right i just
don't think it's as extreme as you i
think it's
halo infinite get over the the goal line
finish
however it drops i think at this point i
don't know if they're willing
to really start clean slate
redo this whole thing you know what i'm
saying throw this whole series x
without doing it twice already that long
bro
didn't they do it twice already from my
understanding they got rid of
the unreal name what does it slip i'm
forgetting the name of the engine now
slip
stream okay space all i know lip stream
listen
all i know is this it's going to be the
question that we i think we all need to
answer both of us
is how long is statins role
really is it ill permanent
he's here this is what he's doing or is
it advisory
to just help get something out that's
going to determine everything
and i do feel this yeah if they if they
falter or this thing comes out it's
still that well received
yeah we set it on unlock shout out to
ryan like
heads are going to roll you know what
i'm saying the vibe i get that's my last
point
the vibe i get is kind of like whether
it be
i don't know if it's phil or it's matt
booty i'm going to assume it's matt
booty because
he's in charge of both of them to be
honest with you right but
bad booty's in charge again he's phil's
old role as far as gabe studios right
it's matt booty because he's not you
know he's not looking at the studios
like he should be
right and it's phil's job for not making
him do his job
but this is what i'm saying at this
point whether it be matt booty
or phil someone came in there like king
said on a parental mode
yup who's doing this good let's [ __ ]
this yeah who's doing the dishes
who's taking out the garbage because
clearly y'all can't get this right
right so i agree it's one of those two i
just don't know who i'm not working
behind the scenes right
so that's the part i like because
finally it's like when i heard the move
i'm like yes
get in there see what's going on in this
kitchen because clearly something is
wrong
the question is which we all got to find
out is
whether it's a whole redo
which i will be shocked or not
and then we're going to re-evaluate
y'all at the po at the moment it's out
and then we could talk about that
i don't think it's a re-do like as as as
in like start over fresh
i just think that they might bring him
in in the back end
and restructure how certain things are
done in the game uh
you know just especially the beginning
middle and then
i mean people we don't know the
beginning middle and then
exactly when you when you boot it up and
you notice that buddy
bearded cop dude ain't dead
the comedy yeah i don't like the cop
i don't like the bloody cop i don't like
i don't like tango and cash
i'm sorry you you can keep tango and
cash
out of my hang i don't need starsky and
hutch in my halo man
so when i boot it up i don't want to see
mel gibson
and danny deville doing the next halo i
don't
want that work so i'm sorry that got
sticker
super chat cause i'm gonna tell you
right now that buddy cop stuff is
finished
[Music]
i think the biggest issue that i do
think is going to happen is
i don't i think realistically we can't
we it's it's almost impossible for them
to start this game
but the thing is like for all we know
they can't even make
like i don't know how engines work can
they take acids from one engine and put
together i would say no
her i heard
i think the most realistic thing we can
expect here is i think
they're going to bring him in to
restructure the foundation
yo i want to know the dude who's
flipping
the interrupts sorry but i want to know
the dude who went from
unreal to slipstream
i want to know who carlett was and is he
fired
continue i think that these individuals
going to come in they're going to
restructure
certain aspects of halo infinite i think
it will get delayed to the end of 21
2022. it will come out at that point
and then these individuals that help
restructure infinite
they're not leaving they
they are going to i do think bonnie ross
isn't going anywhere
but i think she's going to have a less
hands-on approach in terms of the studio
itself
and these people are going to be running
the studio got you all right so i was
going to super chat catch up
we got lonzo 86 with the five dollar
super chat you don't switch to games
engines for graphical issues halo
gameplay was sound
victor not agreeing
no gameplay
they need to get this right because
phil's reputation is also on ice for
funding disaster
they can release gear six next year i
don't know how close they are to that
but
um what else we got see we got jd gamer
with the five dollar super chat my only
concern is that they try and make
a 2021 date for the 20th anniversary
other than that
please take all the time to get it not
good but
great yeah jd gamer i i don't think that
there's any way that they do that
because if they're willing to delay it
out of the series x nothing else is more
important to them than that
so i don't care if it's the 50th
anniversary if they delayed it out of
the series
x window for the game i don't think
they're gonna let that game simmer and
do what it needs to do
and and the pressure's on for it to be
good even more so now
exactly then we have pixel bit g with
the five dollar super chat
let's consider one thing cut scenes
before craig looked amazing
the engine isn't the issue and it's
going nowhere but i did suspect stanton
state i do suspect stanton stays
yep and we have regulator 951 the five
dollars
cutscenes is the game i'm with you kyle
gameplay was on point the game has
graphical problems that can
easily be fixed i think joe's back to
check if the story is on point
right and if the story is not on point
then what happens
oh man i go to your so you mean to tell
me you take a ferrari
with a pinto engine so you you jump in
your beautiful ferrari the cut scenes
look great
but when you go to start that joint up
it's really this is the thing like if
the story's not on point
you think this dude is gonna it's gonna
cost on or whatever they're gonna put
out be like yeah
oh no oh it's a valid point i hear where
you going
jd again with the five dollar super chat
incognito answer to what's going on
is where's bonnie no one's heard from
her since the start of this because
she's probably been demoted or cut out
damn y'all going in oh damn yeah we have
squirrely dan hold on i got jumped a
little bit
squirrely dan with the five dollars over
chat sorry i'm late guys i'm gonna start
from the beginning got to fix my ride so
i can get to work this week
no doubt i want a brother morning it's
fine man we'll do just just for you man
we'll just wait for you to catch up
then we have echelon seven the dark with
the five
chat a token of appreciation for the
lords thank you brothers
thank you bro sifu poetic x initiative
with the five dollar super chat i love
that name yeah
can't believe i don't get tongue tied
when i say it your balls are
crazy when you say his name is jen marco
john mark louise
man i could only dream of you know be
careful what you wish for well i wish
for that two
downs and i got 16.
i could see joseph leading them to an uh
to an
online reboot of halo or what i don't
know
what that means um then we have the wise
old gamer
you don't remember that game ani oh own
them
yeah let me read this the white's okay
we're five dollars super chat shout out
to you man
uh booty comes into three foot they're
asking who bought this tlc
tcl sir i know i i corrected myself
after i said it oh okay
jesus uh we have jd gaming with the two
dollars which has
statin ain't going nowhere and i want my
record too yeah
facts me too brother look at my final
balls look hey don't you even beat
recoil
why are you always going to take credit
for somebody
oh you're going to be dead skills yeah
you always gotta
so yeah i mean look the other thing too
again another great point i believe
desolate gary made
again all unlocked and ryan was one
narrative consistency
right stanton was there during the
day from the halos that are revered
during the bungee joint but the thing
that
really rocked us is when we got the fan
vote question
and the fan was like look at this point
343 has now had
the same amount of years of control of
the halo franchise as bungie
that is mind-blowing to me i did not
realize now
they have had it that long you know what
i mean so it we gonna see i don't know
what's gonna happen
i mean i i definitely even though i
disagree with
you with some of what you guys are
saying i'm not gonna sit there and say
it's not out of the realm of reality
that it could happen it can't happen
right
i'll say this like they look yes they've
had almost as much time with the
franchise as bungie has at the same time
it's still not their baby
right that's what i said yeah it's not
their baby they've been literally
a step-dad the whole time so at the end
of the day
if they can't parent it right then yeah
like king said like alex said then you
gotta
you know give it to the original you
know what i'm saying parent you know i'm
saying at this point
so the key is just going to be how much
they're willing to sacrifice
how much you know from the beginning
yeah that's going to be the key so we'll
see what happens the development was big
this week
we got a lot going on so we got more on
everybody let's get the bars off
and then get this into attic's topic man
addict man
you ready for that call of duty which
version you get yeah
i'm gonna let you pop this off i don't
even want to he would talk
about your topic
you you presented to the realm listen
man
call of duty uh what is it uh black uh
call of duty black ops cold war a lot of
confusion
going on in the internets and uh looks
like there are
all these different upgrade paths
whether you buy a digital
whether you buy a physical then what
version the current gen and if you're
upgrading
so i want to break it to the room have
you guys seen all of this because
it is wild i have all the documentation
up here
but it's like playstation 4 got the
option
to upgrade the playstation 5 again
digitally through the playstation store
the xbox one will not have the option
to the upgrade to the series x through
the microsoft store at launch
then there's a different set of rules
for the physical joint
this is crazy also shout out to dizzy
man he's got a great one
up on logicgaming.net you already know
what time it is um
as far explaining this way better than i
am because i i i'm still confused
what's going on so i'm going to bring
you back to you addict man like uh with
all these versions all listed and then
also what about the point a lot of these
update they're charging for the upgrade
yep yeah they're just saying we're doing
this off the love we charge you
so addict but i'll bring back to you
what you feel about this man
i think i think like look i i'd love to
say
i'm personally can't say let's boycott
this game because i wasn't gonna buy
this game anyway
right but you know i feel like man we
let them get too much man we didn't get
too comfortable
and if we let them start this at the
beginning of the generation
we are they're gonna do with the whole
generation like and to me did you guys
to my knowledge just from what i
saw in the i don't know someone in the
chat someone in the room definitely
correct me if i'm wrong
but you have to buy the ultimate edition
to even get an upgrade version
for the series x you can't even
you can't buy the standard edition and
upgrade it later
they won't let you unless you have a
playstation and i'm just like
wow that's like i don't even think that
playstation paid for that's the money
that's good they are literally putting
an
upgraded version behind the paywall yeah
that's their playstation playing dirty
yeah but i was playing dirty too yeah
it's just all across the board
activision saying they're gonna get this
bread
like like no matter how you slice it no
matter where you go which one you cop
some way you pay an upgrade some way
i just personally feel like as a
community
we need to stop supporting these kind of
acts like
it's one thing you know i don't i don't
i don't particularly care for
uh you know dlc that's exclusive uh
because i feel like
you're asking your consumers to pay um
for more for a game that you get less
product or the same for a game you get
less product
i don't mind exclusives i don't mind
timed exclusives because they put that
money and
it's not being withheld from anyone it's
it's being
it's being withheld from a whole
audience but it's not being with
there's nothing in that game that's
different in another version
right so i don't mind that because you
know they're paying for the whole
title as an entity for a certain amount
of time or an entire
uh entirety and when it comes to
exclusives in general
i do mind this though because not only
are we hot we're hiding dlc behind stuff
now
now we're hiding features behind behind
the paywall
and i think there's something wrong with
that like we got to stop
letting these companies do this destiny
stuff to us letting these companies do
this
you know uh you know the the marvel
thing that was different you know the
spider-man thing that made sense
because they they have the spider-man
game that makes sense but this
doesn't you know uh the control scenario
same thing
they they literally came out like look
we know we have this whack game
that's what they say you know this is
this is exactly what this
is you know what what i read when i read
when i read their statement addict world
with a c
said this okay
okay guys we know we have this
this this bad game you know it's it's
okay but
midway through the game but you know we
didn't make the greatest
amount of money we did okay we did okay
but since we just did okay and you get
and you guys didn't really support us
to to to the promised land we're going
to make you buy this game again
i think we'll see you got
so you guys are going to have to let me
have this lisp
so everybody who said gabriel do good so
you're gonna pay this bread
and to me i just like you know
this is the time where we say yo we
ain't about this
we ain't buying your game you don't love
your bro
no no clearly you know you know
this isn't what's going to happen but i
got to give up
i got to take my hat off to people like
you know the pc
crowd because for the most part when
they don't like something
they stand up they really do we can't
say they don't like
they have literally stopped
multi-million dollar corporations like
steam from doing
stuff they didn't like i will say and i
i feel like
how big social media is now go out there
like if you don't like something i'm not
about that
speak with your wallet stuff you can
speak with your wallet but i want you
adding these people on twitter
too because they need to feed that fire
i want that community manager
to want to turn his phone off because
he's getting so many apps this man
what's the revolution
oh quick question the only thing i will
say that seemed a bit strange
was that for my understanding if you
do not pay for the upgrade version
right of the current generation on the
next
that it does work with backward
compatibility however you do not get any
next-gen
features like ray chasing i thought
that was hilarious you gonna pay for
that
you can play it over here but you gonna
play it in the basic version of the new
system i thought that
was the most stick them up whole at
that situation because you're not you're
actually not unlocking anything
it's already there for you they're
literally
what are doing is they are literally
holding pushing uh pushing a button in
your system
saying that you're playing on the xbox
one at
who you're playing on the xbox they are
literally
they are literally holding that button
and was and you come over there you're
like yo i got the console
why didn't i get the before because you
go give me that knot
we got the kiddie pool for you this this
section is your section
i i could just see like a bouncer a big
bouncer i'm trying to get the club he's
like
hey i was in the back i got everything i
you know i got the fly stuff on let me
in that club
give me that 9.99 i'm like what do you
mean i just
paid you that wasn't enough that was
last year
we have black ronin 357 with the five
dollar super chat say something please
please you please
uh we have jonathan b with the five
dollar super chat so you're telling me
sony backed up the truck
for an exclusive paywall excellent job
unlocked car great to see you on that
thank you brother you already know
salute
uh then we have smitty smith with the
five dollar super chat activision
run your pockets and give me the house
what you got on my drink right that
run the jewels whoo we're good all right
cool so what's up man you
the our resident call of duty
connoisseur that buys everything yeah
you know you we know you're the first
one alive for that uh that death match
you know i have to appreciate bobby
codex
candor like i have to appreciate the
fact that he's like
i'm not trying to hide this i'm not yet
literally we have not figured this out
seven years later we're doing the exact
same thing we did in 2013 we're going to
do it again
right yo what can i say like
it's there are 10 different versions of
it
it's not hyperbole and you know what's
crazy
there's an upgrade path where you have
to pay more like it's just
it is i've never in my life seen this
and i appreciate their greed
we are pretty educated in these type of
matters we see it all the time
imagine a casual going to gamestop and
reading these fine prints like
like like they're going to get to like
the third line like what do you mean
this does that
what so i don't get the x i don't get
the what what does this mean
i can see i can see forte with a
blackboard like giving like that
he's gonna have a job you got to teach a
class
forte's gonna have a diagram
it is it is way too much but it it's so
bad that it's funny like and and like
you said
it doesn't matter like gamers do we
don't pay
we don't it was people
[Applause]
that's why i said like look you can't
attack them through wallets because
there's too many people willing to give
them their money
hold on how did chat go have bad
billions we didn't talk about i'm down
with you
jonathan b how you down with the greed
you sounded like king sir you saw that
you go to corporate sir
if you can't if you can't get them
through the money
get them through that social media
presence man they they do care they care
about their
name no no obviously respectfully
like the game is being attacked don't go
out there don't go out there and be like
threatening to like kill people
and people you're not gaming like you
can be like i've always said that you
can get your point across your bars
across and be respected
you could always do it now and there's
plenty of people like
sure maybe 15 000 people not willing to
buy call of duty
maybe them people not willing to buy
college is not going to do nothing to
their wallet
but 15 000 people tagging the the poor
social media dude that's running
activision stuff that's going to get
more across like
like all jokes aside right let me get
the super chat real quick we have uh 21
dean with the five dollar super chat
it's only a 10 upgrade just get the next
gen bundle and you're covered all right
cool you're right about that the problem
is this right and they all jokes are you
pocket watching yeah yeah i was here
when you look at activision and how they
monetize call of duty and they make
money hand over
fists every year with call of duty you
you would think that they could be at
the forefront of look man
just here we you're gonna spend a ton of
money
doing all kinds of different stuff on
our platform whether it be war zone
whether it be whatever the case may be
you're spending a ton of money here it's
just going to be across the board you
buy it once you get
giving you anything exactly and this is
the thing right you would think that the
ones that have the most money
would be like listen guys here
but no that's not the way the real world
is
god it's not the way
he sounds like that friend that friend
that's always trying to get you to not
do some dumb stuff
listen guys this isn't a good idea
and the thing is when you really look at
the situation how did they become that
rich they were the greediest like
they were the ones that said nah you're
gonna pay it you're gonna nickel and
dime you for everything you've got
let me see kick face we're gonna
continue i just got one thing that
happens right now
i just got one thing to say to king in
particular though corporate kayla
smile i just got one thing to say to
king real quick in particular
listen king listen king okay there you
go
they are the epitome of capitalism
and you know i can't be mad at them that
it's just hilarious but i can't be mad
at
that let me get before we go
let me get dizzy real quick with the
five hours the only real question is
whether or not ten dollars is worth
next-gen assets to the gamer we all know
the hardcore cod guys will buy it so
maybe
i can answer that for you no
okay i see you uh shaking your head
let me bring up the hangouts and click
on king's name
beverages first of all the people that
are outraged aren't even gonna have an x
or playstation five
and if you spend the 600 700 for these
systems
you are paying the ten dollars okay so
look my issue isn't the ten dollars my
issue is the fact that they're trying to
like
exclude the xbox community i don't
forget
then then but play on playstation like
it's as simple as that it's as simple as
listen
as simple as that don't limit yourself
buy both consoles and play on the
playstation you play with that they give
you the most
all right now i'm gonna say a company
ain't giving you back
anything they got the hot hand they're
gonna keep feeding him
you gonna keep feeding steph curry and
he gonna keep getting buckets on your
head
all night long because you fools will
continue to run up there with that
they told you blatantly you paying extra
i just and you looked at them in the
face and said
but why it's not because i don't need to
buy the ultimate because
if i buy this one i should be
automatically no
i just like that this year you're
doubling down
i i just personally feel like we
shouldn't
we shouldn't be supporting these type of
haters
i just don't think you should don't buy
call of duty anyway
that's what i'm saying i don't either
but i think i don't think we should
support this kind of music
we shouldn't be
it's just the fact that like king said
you're gonna pay this
and it's and when somebody says but why
the answer is
because
look what this 505 tried to do right
look at what 505 tried to do to explain
away the control thing right
they did nothing they really don't
explain anything
it was literally because they literally
might as well come out there
they said well why are you guys doing
this at 303 it's because we want to
matter yes you know
when you go get your car you brought
your range
and you said what's this two thousand
dollars here
they said gas guzzle attacks
you know that you know what gas goes
with taxes do you know what that is
why i gotta pay that oh you want the
range
well when you get the range it's called
baller fees
all right so you want to ball out with
the series x and the playstation 5.
you want the raid tracing you gonna have
to pay for the ultimate edition
i don't think
people fear the block button you gonna
throw that disc and you thought you
bypassed the security
and that ten dollar swipe card said
swipe now
parade tracing if you do not swipe
at this moment your screen will stay
fuzzy
well it's true it's it's not gonna be
paying for back compat it's gonna be
paying for it
they're charging you for features
everybody else is saying smart delivery
don't you they don't they ain't got the
hot hand
you ain't got you're not call of duty
you gotta give your joint away for free
call of duty ain't gotta listen to
nothing you
saying get down or lay down if not buy
get away from me if you don't got your
ten dollars if you don't get your ten
dollars
i ain't talking to you i don't feel this
alive too much with your face
you know what my girls ain't got to take
that mess that's done
all right let's get these super chat
roles
we got a regulator with the two dollar
super chat with money saved by having
game pass 70
with nothing
we got jonathan b with the five dollar
super chat activision has people making
real decisions do you spend ten dollars
on the next gen upgrade on a new tcl
wow man i really like
i'm starting it didn't bother me at
first but i was not starting to get
it he's starting to get like a shame for
my
tpfl man yo they got they have this
the the c the c10 um
we got smitty smith with the five dollar
super chat activision
we are capitalism at the highest level
hurry up and buy a million salute
cracking with the two dollars super chat
the mario behind king is creeping me out
don't say that you can't be doing it we
just one day one day we're gonna see
that they come to life
and it's just gonna start hey we're
gonna see it go up the stairs and come
down with
a knife splatter on the screen
you ain't never seen chucky man it don't
work
i already paid for the 90 version every
year cod has different version this year
you really have
you have to pay if you want to play the
better version
this is a cross-gen player and we have
sean murray with the five dollar super
chat
my first supper chat i won't be getting
call of duty anywhere
anywhere you do not have to pay that on
pc
so i will get it on pc but he's still
buying it
yeah we have kurt with the five dollar
super chat activision rolled up on craig
and
looked at the bike turned around and
said what up greg
people live in flames let me get the
liverpool plane ea not even this bad
e but the thumping a
this is hilarious man just like why is
it
mad confusing for no reason like it's
just
good
that's because they know they're being
extra and like they don't know how to
word it because they know they're being
extra
but you want to play in the bitties or
you want to play in gaussian
facts gauchos versus the videos do your
tour you know what it is listen shout
out to smitty smell let's get them real
quick if i forget activision
i see we haven't received payment yet
please escort this man out with security
yo just keep coming sean barry doesn't
just still don't have to pay that ten
dollars on pc though
okay i feel that listen at the end of
the day
here's the thing i mean it's just like
you got to have a chart you got to do
all this stuff digital physical
you know what i'm saying shout out to
barry barry it you know he
he like ain't not confusing to me you
know barry is it i feel you
it's not confusing per se it's just
hilarious it's hilarious it's funny like
it's just extra for no reason but mike
barry just said who ain't got ten
dollars
he okay he's definitely fine
oh shout out to the new member of the
room vincent brazil
i want to shout out our chat man you
guys are too good to us like you really
are
really appreciative we got 335 people up
in here man hit that like button
uh you know we definitely got over 300
last week so uh
king got to play that fall guys but you
know that he he he bamboozled me
we were supposed to get 300 at the end
of the show we finished like two
and i was like it's over and then he
gonna tell me in the middle of the week
yo you know we did too
act like my eyeballs wasn't working my
eyeballs was working pretty fine
since this trucker went down notice how
he got all his
uh gear
do you want me to get off this dude on
my phone because i will no
no no no no no
allegations like that
i'm just saying you already ate the meal
now you got your monthly no no listen we
will get the camera situation resolved
it will be done by next week sir
everybody let me get my bars
no man i got that tattoo he gonna get it
we gotta do it right though i don't
wanna see it on the phone i don't see
that yes
philly eagle with the five dollars still
that's a formal problem
just wait for the better version to be
released or paid twice the choice is
simple
that is true that's true
yo they got mad for alerts y'all doing
my boy dirty this camera's messed up
yeah
i'm about to get on my phone man no you
guys are about to
you guys are about to waste this on my
phone yeah
that doesn't count you could do it
with your camera on your phone
moving along anyway like i always say
it's a shame because
with all of this i ain't gonna front
kick this game looking
fire remember how it showed with the 120
and all that yo and they have ronald
reagan out here looking like
for real like it's it's crazy they got
all the features the cross play cross
generation cross war zones zombies
for the first time i think they're doing
uh free post launch content
no season pass and it's a direct sequel
to
uh black ops one from my understanding
so look at the end of the day this is
going to move
so yeah all the talk it's funny you're
saying because all the talk
and i'm not gonna sit here and act like
what they're doing ain't crazy
you don't say they hate a little
slimeball but
gamers man until something dethrones
call of duty
i consistently see them get away it will
murder man activision they know it's
like king says like they know they got
it so they're getting away with this
they're definitely getting away with
this that's all i got
yo soon as the pre-orders went up they
made their money
[Laughter]
it is what it is so we gonna move on get
this topic going with
solve and some ratchet and click sir
so yeah shout out to y'all for the your
reaction show
on thursday forget to come opening night
i i'm fortunate i could not be there but
always entertaining to listen to it
afterwards right so
so my topic is so after gamescom opening
night
and after seeing the the gameplay demo
ratchet and clank
on twitter there was a lot of reactions
saying where
is gameplay for the xbox series x after
scratching clank a lot of people just
like look we
finally see something on the system
playing on the system
where is series x gameplay and beyond
that
beyond that criticism there was a lot of
criticism directed at directly at like
the marketing team
of of xbox and why more hasn't been done
to market these games especially now
with halo infinite not being there
how do you market the system moving
forward just two months away
theoretically two months away from
launch
right so what do you guys think about
that is this
sort of criticism warranted is it unfair
do we i mean it's two months away and we
haven't seen
any games let me go first oh lord
[Music]
hold up let me get let let me go google
hang on quick look at your name i gotta
see this
you gotta focus on him
the best part of you frauds is your
cabin
for two month old footage yeah you know
we saw it officially
running off a playstation yesterday that
was two months ago
off of a playstation it was extended
footage
it was what did you get the wrong cut
what you was so you was upset now
they took away the chopped and screwed
and gave you the full extended version
it's like they literally just put their
okay how you guys can see the loading
screens
so we were we were not impressed i was
not impressed with 15
frames per second was you yo and then
when i started dissecting
it more wow let's say yo
all that is that that that pulling into
the next world
or bringing it closer that's the
glorified jump button
he's
[Music]
first of all how come you got to make a
choice
if you want to play it in 4k
there's a choice how come he's a choice
he's not wrong there he's not wrong
though
is either 4k 30 or whatever the hell
they come up with
60 frames 64. but whatever they come up
it's not
4k 60. whatever or maybe whatever they
come up with resolution
they come up with whatever 1440p
60 and then what was up with those
frames though
mm-hmm what what what and it was only
running in 720
god i got it on my phone you out of
control kick so you were not impressed
you
i was not impressed at all because i
played ratchet and clanked out of the
date i got it upstairs right now uh-huh
so nothing about that show
and all gameplay god bless wow
yo you know who put me on the game i'm
not even gonna i ain't even gonna tell
because he's a great developer he put me
up on again he said yo you know when
that train is coming right there that's
a loading screen
yeah no no he's not he's not lying that
that
that is literally how they do stuff like
that and i i i noticed that from the
from the start but you know i i wasn't
trying to be messy but apparently we're
being messy so
with that fast ssd
i thought the ssd was supposed to fix
the frames how come it was 15 frames per
second
wow where was the frame
this is why we get cold xbox
because literally while we get called
these are the dislikes this right here
is the 13th
i take all 17 of them your big mad
your big man it was 15 frames per second
y'all didn't even know if it was
if it was so king how do you know
they're not little man
no no i know they big mad because they
got tcl's
oh my god so just to clarify king you
are saying they're frauding because they
have the nerve
to have an optional 60 frames per second
ball and can't do the 4k 60 on itself
you're awesome keep the weight in the
machine
you're also saying that the rift ssd
between the desks does not
impress you that's just a joke did it
impress you
yes all he did was he okay literally
it was right in front of him he could
have jumped to it he said
no i'm going to pull the world to me
he's not wrong
is doing that it's a lazy button
it's an easy button you don't want to
jump so you press the button
no hold up hold up i gotta agree with
king we gotta be real here
like he could have easily have jumped up
there
regardless of what you like regardless
if you liked what you saw which i think
ratchet clayton looks great yeah
we can't sit here we can't see her act
like
it's like a huge i literally saw people
in this community
saying that it is such a leap in bounds
from last gen
and what i saw i was like you know it
looks good but i just don't see that
huge
jump okay i get that part i will give
y'all
that maybe you guys ratchet fan y'all
don't feel that
a huge graphical jump okay maybe i'll
let that rock but my question is to
solve this question
right they have shown game play
that for the most part is impressive
unlike
the same place unlike
some other console where we got
craig faces and stuff disappearing and
pixelating
and come on that's what i'm trying to
say you know what the difference is
we was real about that we we called
craig out we said craigslist
we're being real about this okay they
got lo they got train loading screens
let's not talk about astro bots beta
where the loading screens was like what
king like 10 seconds long and listen and
add it
when they was falling through the world
that was cgi
oh my god tell the truth shame the devil
i'm not going that far
because you know what y'all didn't fool
me well it was a falling between lowell
so that was really disgusting like no no
no
i thought it looked good it's just like
being realistic
yes okay i'm sorry last point i'll give
it back to y'all y'all said it looked
good
but y'all like it ain't oh my god like i
y'all not there
right y'all just saying look to me like
when it comes to uh
first off uh we are we gonna talk about
the fact that look at jabari
i'm jay parker i'm trying to rock for
playstation i see what they doing
let's see what they doing i'm trying to
get those dislikes up to 200.
this
to knife playstation
have been touting we doing playstation 5
on the games we doing this we doing that
and to me i wanted to see
that now look i'm not saying that
latching clank did not look impressive
okay
[Laughter]
to be realistic with you oh i don't i'm
not i don't even care about ratchet and
clay
but i will tell you it looked like a
great game to play
now they said launch window a lot of
people in this community think launch
windows a month
it's not it's up to six months we can
potentially get this game
six months from launch are we gonna talk
about the fact that spider-man has not
been shown
and that game's supposed to come out in
two now that's factual
tell the truth shane the devil
we have sean murray with the five dollar
super chat we saw gears five
uh two weeks ago a port running on xbox
364 months ago and
unless we're talking about next-gen they
though they did say game play yeah but
it's
it's gears 5 running on a series x i
mean
fantastic but it's not
looked good it looked like it was a
solid experience but it wasn't solid
because it was shaky
it was a solid experience you called 15
frames per second
solid yeah disrespectful somebody need
to polish
that's like i told those dudes i said i
can't wait to digital foundry get a hold
of you and they got a hold of them
afterwards so you know what that sound
of him hitting his hand that that's him
smacking the sony people
no that's the tlt smacking because you
know what the tlc dude said
the tlc dude
gotta be out my back like this man he
got me saying
tlc pcl dudes
they are fine they were happy with what
they saw
right i will speak for the tlc
uh the tcc community
we are okay with what's going on because
they're going to play in performance
mode
mm-hmm
i will speak for us again uh as a
representative of of of the tcl
community we are definitely playing
performance monkeys
saying shave the devil y'all don't
encourage you know we have element
appeal with the five dollars which
ratchet gameplay looked nice but it was
still the same slice of not more
polished a re-wrapped burger wow
wow i love it
let the church say amen
don't encourage that shame the devil
we've got zero one nine four d with the
two dollar super chat this is the last
two dollars to my name won't be eating
today
wow oh brother we appreciate the support
but please eat
man i'm sure you can get some saltine
crackers at your local dollar store
then we have the living flame with the
five dollars super chat crispy saying
reflections is ray tracing spirit pharah
got reflections by xbox one
yes we retraced that early yeah like a
lot of people
do kind of use ray tracing
interchangeably with other things
so we caught up oh no we're not caught
up actually i got jumped for a minute
hold on
we have regulator with two dollar super
chat did you not see the ssd working on
the medium
oh yeah yeah yeah but the medium wasn't
running on the series x that's the
problem wow
i'll i'll take over for the next couple
of ones we gotta find out the super chat
from pixel bit
g ratchet and clank portal jumping on
railroad wow the black ground is f
uh
no interactions shark did it better
also not coming until mid 2021
this man said super shark did it better
i'm done man
you know what pixel bit g you might be
on to something let's get some on just
something there in the chat
i reluctantly gave that on to something
continue
listen man uh i like ratchet and clank i
think the particle effects and the
craziness of what's going on on the
screen
compared to the old version is trying to
bonkers what they're doing
yes but beyond that like when you look
the general gameplay and all that stuff
like
it hasn't changed a lot like so it is
very much a a ratchet and clank game in
the vein of the 2016 version
just prettier like super prettier right
and it remains to be seen how this how
this world jumping thing works
if it does feel like it's on rails if it
if it is kind of dynamic in the game
world i guess we'll figure that out
we'll see when it comes out
um but it's on the machine thank you
it's on the machine and tell the truth
shame the devil
no no we will talk about that time
preach wait it's
we have the interviewer we have the
developer and we have a gamer
playing the game that's what we're doing
i see no controller i didn't see
anything i'm just taking somebody's word
for it
and sony lies right now
at all until i see a controller and not
the same demo doing the same moves
in the same areas i don't trust you
buddy
if they're lying right if they're lying
let's assume xbox is lying to you right
exactly literally they they
literally have not showed anything on
series x hardware
they literally have shows
yes we have literally not seen anything
on that box look at that cubicle
oh god have we seen it other than
mock-ups and 3d graphics
correct correct okay no no correct no no
you're all right
you're right you're same token i have
not seen an xbox series externally
listen i haven't seen that so so check
this out we have seen
both companies frauding yes right to
some people
in our mind yeah we're gonna call
that's right but if one is showing you
the box and all its innards
and the other dude keeps showing you cgi
graphics of the
what the conceptual renders
nobody's got a playstation 5 in their
head are they telling you this is
gameplay
what are you playing on bro i don't
believe the other one has been touting
the most
i'm going to send you a message real
quick i just needed to sell them okay oh
my god
while we do that we got somebody who
joined the realm medic jay rob put the
crest up in there put the horns up in
there
brother that joined the room yeah put
them up in there
[Music]
super chats if you want so if you gotta
smith with the two dollars which had the
devil is a lie
shame him john murray with the five
dollar super chat again they shoot
they they showed the gears 5 and quick
resume on xbox series x
yes it's gears 5. it's a game that runs
at 4k
60 on the x1x you're not
showing me why i need a series x
[Music]
now you're changing now you playstation
in it
don't you like to pick heroin listen
you saw them have the box there put the
disc inside
with a cool friend okay we did not see
this information
from the police station
they're fraught so this is what
ps5 dead kid is not a ps5 sorry brother
wow
all right all right then we have we got
matt j rod
welcome to
that's not true we've seen austin evans
didn't finally play games on xbox it was
a physical breakdown
yes all right all right let me let me
clarify here get it let's go
huge stuff new stuff it's an indie game
show
the game haven has shown 10 minutes of
gameplay and on screen says capture on
the series x at gamescom
um
yes but we want something that that
actually
shows what that console could do first
of all okay so
back to the other part of my question
yes marketing team
why is this not being yelled from the
tops of mountains
this is game play on the xbox series x
they don't need to yell when they write
that's people wanting to know when you
write where is these playstations in the
wild
wow nobody got it you know what the only
person we saw with a controller was jeff
keagley
yes and he was blowing it was going on
remind you and was it it was doctor
disrespect no doc this disrespect had a
fake controller
you
that's my thing like why is this not
being screamed from the mountaintops
listen this is xbox series x
the thing about gamepl is it's probably
not impressive it's probably not what we
want to see
and it's not impressing the way ratchet
is impressing yes there
anybody who's that did not impress me
sir oh my god
for yourself
no check it out the first time you see a
magic trick you're mystified
but hold up let's let mom disappear let
me say something before you guys
continue going down this rival
yes um you know do i i think ratchet and
clank brings value because it's only on
ps5 but i do not think ratchet and
claims bring value in terms of
excited because it looks like it's a
next-gen lead like
i i do think ratchet click look very
impressive and it looked like a fun game
but i don't think it looks like
something that you know is a drastic
improvement from
ratchet and clank one you know it's a
pay wall it's a whole
lot that game could be done
on your regular play through the rest
they could do the rest of the
playstation 4.
no you won't be doing
dislikes how deep is pulling the screen
too
if that's the power of your ssd you are
insert trouble brother
you know what this d could do is pull a
screen forward
a couple of inches you're done son
last week we went in on microsoft it's
sony's turn
let's say listen
okay just making sure all right so we
got to find out from jonathan b
i thought we hated cartoony games but we
cap him for
larissa oh ratchet and clay i'm not
being messy like that right
all right so we got a five dollar super
chat from shrimp kingdom
phil don't care if you buy an xbox
series x that's just
his passion let me get my
did we get the artemis dude get it just
no yes
okay we gotta find out super chat from
artemis the game
okay okay we got that oh jade
we gotta find out super superchat from
j-dub y'all got me
dying over here
today let me get my balls
yeah i can't believe themselves i can't
believe them here's the deal here's the
deal look
am i going to you know what's funny he
be acting like he don't know us
i'm not right now right now right now
i get it it is
the consensus in the world was impressed
by the ratcheting that's what a
square circle listen listen they are
impressed with
nothing special they are impressed with
tcl
how are you going to see and use the
playstation fan base
as a consensus on what is impressive and
what do you think
the majority 150 million billion
but the millions in the chat were
thoroughly impressed
they won't be able to get one and the
consensus
is xbox series x we have a gameplay
problem
for the most part we have not seen
things no we don't got a gameplay
problem we got a you probably a hard one
right see what you like about the ssd
say what you like about you wasn't
impressed with the frame rate or
whatever it may have been
the fact is they offer the 60 frames per
second mode the ray tracing on clank
looked phenomenal
the game looked fun right
you know does it come with ray tracing
they said it's ray tracing on it
you know what you know what hurts me the
most 100 p yes you know what hurts me
the most king
is the fact that we can never continue
to never be doing this messy stuff with
us man he always got to be the middle
ground
person no i'm telling y'all i'm not a
ratchet man dude
i'm not a ratchet like dude this is not
i told y'all for the launch the only
thing that excited me
was miles morales i was hoping for god
for godfall did not impress me
this is not my back i've never bothered
writing a clan there's no disrespect i
know the game is fun
i know millions let's see the difference
between me and you i know
millions love something i don't like
well i do too i just don't care that's
different yeah i know you don't care
this is addict's work i just don't care
these other people ain't buying this
playstation for me man i buy this
playstation so why do i
care what they like i feel you all i'm
saying is the perception i know
you two feel differently but the rest of
the world
no i'm playing the game what i'm saying
is
i'm saying this right these dudes is
jumping around like they saw the
reinvention of the wheel
okay so it's gonna cap it too hard and
i'm gonna tell you this
that's my thing too i i i do think
they're capping too i would say that's
my thing
those are the ttl
basic playstation dudes a place a dude
with a playstation pro
a better television says yo
i really don't see the reason to upgrade
right and those are the people
that are watching saying get that i get
when you go from the highest fidelity
guy but
add to your point the majority owns the
tcl
right so the majority are going to be
impressed
they might buy in the place how you feel
about that
yeah how you feel how you feel today the
tcl people are
high connoisseur that you are
where you're able to differentiate the
pixels and show
that it's not that much of a job
of gaming you know why because cog is
acting like he's one of y'all
dog is acting like he's one of y'all
okay you know what i gotta tell the
truth and shame the devil oh
god i gotta tell the truth for shane the
devil cause if tv
tells if it's 4k native or not yeah
right or wrong
correct is that a tcl i just
come on hold on one thing one thing i i
i gotta get this guy right now
do not let him run not let him run
does it say uh is that a tcl first sir
well the tco that
determines whether or not there's a
television a tcl
no i do not have a tcl okay you do not
have
television tells you if it's a 4k native
or not
it tells you the resolution of what
you're watching yeah correct it also
tells you if you have hdr right
yes correct right now
so all the tcl havers it's
foreign you're part of the group
you're you're with me hold on hold on no
no
i gotta represent the tcl community all
right
uh i have a tco and it does tell me what
i'm doing
thank you daddy see he's been so
far removed from tcl he don't even know
that they've upgraded
this is this this is my issue
don't worry about that we got a section
for you
look man the the tcl community
does not like this backlash that's going
on right now all right
we demand that this goes back a little
bit let me finish my boss at the end of
the day i get what y'all saying y'all
not a broken
all i felt was the huge news to solve
point
is whether it's six months three months
launch window is a big deal i thought
2021 late you know what i'm saying like
i didn't think it was that close which
again
adds another blow to halo infinite not
being there right
they're killing it to no
gameplay really shown yet and here's my
thing
i know to king's point i i when i look
at bright memory infinite did y'all see
the latest brightman
i still ain't watching oh my lord this
looks phenomenal
when i see ex marketer right
oh my lord this looks phenomenal it's
just that i shouldn't have to be
deep diving and going through somebody's
website that channel
to find this footage that's all i'm
saying microsoft
that's what i'm seeing y'all it's not
that i'm not saying microsoft can't do
it we know what it is we see what the
hood is we know what the specs are
in the part let me get my last point
over there my last point is they've
they've got to do a better job of
showcase there's right now people saying
yeah you talking with your chest out
but we're not seeing you hit the gym and
and move them weights like you saying
you moving
whereas these dudes we stay outside and
they move and wait
regardless of whether you think it's
only 50 pounds or whatever it is
they're moving game play weight on that
console right
that's all i will say before you go real
quick i will say that
they've been very vocal how strong their
console is but they've showed literally
nothing
to so to show that all right
to me when it comes to stuff like that
like that's not necessarily like
you know you guys know me i'm not the
really biggest person on i got i got a
tcl tv i don't care about like
now for now for now look we ain't
talking about the future we're talking
about
right right now you're with them for now
you're sympathized with them you'll
sympathize
xbox typing too much on twitter about
their gym status but haven't updated
against the grammys
we are not we are not going there i've
seen diller talk about it i've seen
rand talk about it like the xbox
community
he's not talking about the community
he's not talking about the computer he's
talking about xbox themselves he's not
talking about his clients oh yeah
the community we rock we rock okay king
uh the the tcl ambassador gives you
permission
yes okay okay okay get your footage we
got to move on no
it's just you know we're beating a dead
horse
okay um microsoft i think they put all
the eggs in the in
in the barrel with halo yes i
i think they had a huge rollout a huge
marketing campaign and i think that was
supposed to kick off in august right
after the show
and i think they thought they was going
to ride halo all the way through
to show game play and uh be the poster
child
uh for their marketing and when that
fell apart
it's like yeah oh snap yep that that and
that
it's funny you said that because i had
this discussion with a couple of people
offline
and i again it it was too much
put in that basket they thought it was
there and if it was dead they would have
been fine
right hey louie i had the one free to
play 120 frame uh multiplayer mode
a full open world halo they could have
held the fourth down with that flagship
game and now that it's not it's a
glaring weakness i say this
i say this all right
and i want the the the public
to listen from this standpoint right
xbox gave their finished product
to austin evans yes digital foundry yes
sir
and they did monthly breakdowns on
and they even showed how to build it
factual and everything
they showed it working in front of you
yeah they showed it in hand
yeah i get that king but at the end of
the day they showed you the console they
showed you how to write
them up but they show what games are let
me see
my piece okay
sony showed you footage
and at the bottom it says captured on a
playstation
5. right
we have an issue with this okay
something's about something
okay he's talking too slow man i'm
scared i
have an issue with liars
i have an issue with liars when you lie
people tend not to believe you
so they have lied to me for years
and i don't believe them
so when you don't produce
your console you don't give it to a
third
party oh okay i see you break it
when you don't have it in front of you
showing
it's like we got to take your word for
it right listen
put the disc in show me ratchet and
clank
i'm with you with the hardware though i
wish you would like it
i don't trust you bro you didn't earn
nothing from me microsoft
knew that you didn't trust them
and gave their hardware up until you
do the same you will be treated
the same i don't believe your
footage you'll believe what more people
i feel you said your whole thing is
until a third party like a digital
foundry like an australian
gets a playstation 5 in talk
in breakdown and then showing stuff
then you are more like that's why you
are staying on your own
fight okay you know what look like but i
understand where you're coming from i
understand where you're coming from yeah
that's good
but you guys get super jazz all right we
got the alerts
murray with the father yeah for sure
i love it it's an insomniac making
spider-man morales how you have gameplay
footage on ratchet and clank but not
spider-man
i i think the spider-man yeah they
wanted a suspect i agree with that part
i do agree
yeah yeah and that it's that's a little
worrisome yep yeah we got
the medic with the two dollar super chat
what about vizio though king
yo you know what not for nothing it was
a point in time
when vizio was going so i think sony was
giving them their screens
i think it was that or they was
providing it's vizio providing the
screen
video providing the screens to sony uh
or whatever
remember it's it's not exactly
that it's it's it's the cpu that's
inside the television
the bit rate and stuff like that right
we can go on and on for days hit me in
uh on twitter and we'll talk about that
stuff right there and listen
if you're happy with your tcl be happy
with it
all right look it is what it is so we
caught up sir uh no we got gotham guy
with the 10
super chat all microsoft have to do is
bundle cyberpunk 2077 with the console
at launch to shut all this nonsense up
because all they have to do because even
the most jamie sodium
dated sony fan knows that a free
cyberpunk trumps the sixty dollar miles
morales
i don't know about that family spiderman
man
at least at least cyberpunk's a full
game oh
wow you can tell we have rich chrysler
with the five dollar shipping chat yo
king lying to everyone he getting paid
big time for promoting tcl
i don't know why i didn't cover like
getting a bag from tcl only five yeah
[Music]
with the five dollar super chat all
these vegetarians in the chat
happy capping about quit with that you
look silly capping for a problem
soon he's talking that real philly talk
yo easy philly
oh don't go hard on the ball
easy philly anyway look so finishing
where we got to move up finishing this
topic my my thing is that i just
i'm gonna buy these consoles if they had
nothing coming out day one because
that's just me right they could be like
yo we got nothing for you day one all
both of them and i'm gonna be online day
one to pick them up that's just me
king's the same cock's pretty much the
same like we're gonna do that
it's just disappointing to me that at
this point there's
no nothing that i i can look to on the
xbox side that i'm like oh wow this is
gonna blow me away like
last gen i was excited i was excited to
see um
killzone shadow fall um on the
playstation side
on the xbox side rise and dead rising
three
day one was like okay it's something new
it's especially rise i was like wow
yeah it's beautiful and i'm just
disappointed that there's not going to
be that
you know it doesn't feel like at least
this point that it's not going to be
that and it's worrisome that we're two
months away from the launch of these
consoles
and we don't have concrete we don't have
price we don't have concrete evidence
this is strange yeah and that was just
the strangest thing i've ever seen
it's strange and i understand the covert
thing and i know king king's original
um topic was going to be more about
whether these consoles should just hold
up and just both
hold up 21. um and then
i would listen i would be super pissed
off if they come out
and they're trying to they're trying and
trying and trying and they get to the
point where they realize that they just
it doesn't make any sense to come out
this year and at the last minute they
they tell us
2021 both don't know
i think one of them is waiting for the
other one to say it
i don't know none of that this i mean
maybe i don't think that because
both of them lost huge amounts of money
microsoft was able to make
money through game pass and other things
in their services and you know
playstation was able to sell
uh huge amounts of last of us too oyster
shima stuff like that
but they still lost money yeah
because the traffic the stores are
closed but when the stores are closed
and your product is sitting inside store
shelves you're not making money
and then something mentioned i think
last week or the week before it's just
that
all these marketing deals they had in
place
yeah it's either either you shove them
right and you move it for whenever
you're along the console or you still
rock with it but again like
we we saw leaks of this the doritos
stuff and whatnot
usually that stuff is is is happening
yeah it's happening i
think they have no choice but to put the
consoles out yeah that's gonna be one of
them
it's coming out it's just we got to see
what these lineups look
let's get moving we got to go we're
going on late and then it's uh
king this is your drink we can frame it
[Applause]
uh some some news in the in in in the
atmosphere right now i can't brought it
to my attention oh
looks like yeah new nintendo switch
rumored again
2021 you know supposedly with 4k support
huge new game lineup a shout out to
bloomberg i've got takashi
only thing this 4k pros doing is letting
them play at 900 beats
let's get out of ours though oh yeah i
mean apparently like i said the rumors
just started making the rounds again out
of a new supply chain
in our taipei and again it's come back
up into the uh you know pretty much uh
gaming news and this time
again featuring supposedly featuring
better specs and
4k graphics output hello king
i did not put this topic out yo so don't
come with me
because the chat was already on me like
oh cake i already know what cog doing
so this is king stuff so no i kidding
i'm going to give it back to you this is
your topic
hold on the wise whole game with the
2000 chat
the 4k switch is the rumored series s
yeah we got this pizza two dollars super
chat the podcast is over
blame your mans blame your message you
always coming for me blame your man
all right so uh if you guys aren't
excited you should be
um i think uh nintendo
sleeping with the current switch that's
in place now not to stand still
but the current switch that's in place
right now
i believe that they just took a flyer on
it
because the wii u was so bad so i
believe that they
put out a console that they can
purposely make money off the rip
and if it's a failure then you know it's
a failure and then they have other
options
but this one from the specs and stuff
that they're talking about
this one looks like this is a
full-fledged console
that they're going forward with and
nintendo is trying to graph
grab the brass ring we always claim that
they don't have the
uh the resolution to compete with the
other guys right
so this switch pro if it's producing in
4k
it must have a tegra 2 or tegra 3 engine
in it
and the the switch that we currently
have now has done
impressive feats like play the witcher 3
even if it's a little bit money
but that's because they throttle back
the console right if they don't throttle
back
the console it can produce better
visuals
so i believe that this next switch
that's coming out
4k and i believe in undock mode if
it keeps the same form factor right
undock mode would probably be 1080p
right right and that's that's a hell of
a boost
that's fantastic right
i'm saying can they come out with a 4k
switch and just blast the competition
more than what they're doing now right
right with the subpar
console that they have let me get this
because
i've been waiting on this let me just
get my voice off a little first
um all right switch cover did hot by the
way if i had
got to put that out you know switch
coming out but uh listen
do i think something is happening yes i
think something is happening
switch gang has been weird this year
because it's like
the switch community is actually mad at
them they're selling like hot cakes
but the switch community right now is
kind of like yo fam where's the big
first party games where's metroid
where's
breath of the wild like you you they are
being so secretive with the second half
of the year
and they keep upsetting people with
these mini directs
that no one really cares for you don't
say like little indie jump offs and
stuff like that
so here's the thing
i still struggle to think nintendo cares
about 4k
that's a little [ __ ] i i love god bless
grandpa in his heart
i just don't see him now don't get me
wrong
if they do it yeah absolutely if there's
some type of upscale or whatever
whatever
i'll be i'll be happy for it i think
though the argument to king's
defense is that something is cooking
because we're supposed to have been got
breath of the wild too
it feels like things are getting pushed
back for a reason and the question is
why is that right
why are we not they're not their usual
boisterous self don't get me wrong this
is not affecting revenue they're not
affecting sales because they out here
you know what i'm saying they're still
out here moving and shaking and grooving
and winning all the time
but the thing is it does feel 20 21 they
they're lining up for something
the thing all i mean i agree with you
king three skews couldn't work
you've got the light aka the standstill
that you call it you know
for the the entry level that's the
little series s you know there
then you got the regular boy with the
full you know joint that could be the
you know xbox one x and then they can
make this like their series x so to
speak this which pro
that could work and they could have
three different price points i could see
it
um for me i honestly don't even care
about the [ __ ] bro can you get some
voice chat
bro can you get some bluetooth can you
guess can you get these basic features
that we
the rest of gaming has been having now
if they got those
in there right and the fact that i will
say this to king's point
because we all we all know about
scalability in here and
we've talked about it at nauseam but
there's going to come a point now
on religion 5 all this other stuff
coming out it's going to get harder to
put these bangers down to this day
series x playstation 5 out here so they
gonna need to make a move so even if
they have the lowest common dominator of
an xbox one base
or a playstation 4 base whether it be
cpuis whatever gpu wise
i don't know what the the latest tegras
are doing but if the tigers is in there
you know what i'm saying yeah that's
going to be a good move because then
they can get those third party bangers
down there on the low end because switch
again don't care about all that
resolution to be honest
they don't they just want the game
they're happy witcher is running
they're like yay we out here you know
what i'm saying so we'll see i'll give
it to eddie because he comes
landing in the door what you call it
this is the super chats
get this super chat stitch with the five
dollar super chat let's be honest
nintendo made money from selling
cardboard
this could be the 1080 natives the 1080
native switch undocking possibly 1440p
dot right what else we got that was it
there we go all right cool addict yeah
resident switch hey let's go
look man i don't care about any of these
like
they can make a switch pro thing it
doesn't bother me i don't care if they
do i don't care if they do
i don't care if they don't because like
at the end of the day i buy a switch for
their first party stuff
and they make they don't make very
graphically demanded games so
if they make it if they don't make it
i'm still going to get the games i want
to play
so so that's pretty much as far as that
goes like
4k switch does that excite you it is
what it is like
there's nothing about that that makes me
want to like because
they're not going to be able to like
replace my pc or my xbox like
right so like as long as what if they
actually do all the stuff i say like
they fixed the major problems and they
got the voice chat and they got all this
that's that i want that more than
anything i don't know i'd rather have
that i'd rather them come out and say
look yo you know
um we are going to improve and make our
games in the 21st century
we're gonna make our network actually
you know make sense but
we're gonna have to sacrifice you know
the fidelity of the of
the calling so i'm like do it every time
do it because at the end of the day
um there's just so much potential a
switch has
that i feel like the attendance just
doesn't care and i'm there with you
i don't think nintendo cares about 4k
narrative yeah
they're clearly winning the console
without it so like
they they don't because you know it's
awfully funny that switch starts winning
every mpd and we don't talk about mpd's
much anymore so
you know because it's they've won it so
many times that people just success
expect it by now yeah no that's not the
current metric the current metrics
engagement so nobody cares about that
solve i mean i agree with everything you
guys have said so far i don't think they
care about this 4k
um you know because honestly the the
base system they would have to create to
push 4k
visuals uh to a tv i think is
it it's probably a little more expensive
than they care to do with
what is just going to be a hardware
revision right it's going gonna be
so i just don't think that they they
care about that a nice 1080p screen like
king said
um on debate on the on the portable
console i think they still understand
that the
portability of that thing is what really
sells it um i don't want them to
i don't want them to ever try to get
back in bed with microsoft and and
playstation in terms of
doing what they do they have been able
to be successful this time around
after they walked away from the wii u by
being different
anything that they do to try to bring
them up to and compete directly with
these guys
i think is a detriment to them they need
to keep focusing on what makes them good
so like you said i don't really even
care the bluetooth stuff in terms for
headphones and stuff fantastic yes i do
need that that and that's
ridiculous not to have um but again
increase the cpu speed
increase the gpu power give me a 1080p
screen
give me give me these um these features
audible side exactly voice chat and
integrated the damn concept exactly
just give me something again that is
gonna take these newer games right and
be able to scale them in a way
that's even better than what you know
what you're getting on the bass switch
now which is not super
super muddy like vaseline all day long
so yeah i that that's what i want and i
think that's what it's going to be i
just don't see them
investing the r d and giving us a
powerful system that you can plug in
and and compete graphic
with what's coming down the pipeline
from xbox and playstation i don't think
that
game is i don't think it's it makes
money for them so
this is what i want and it's time and i
think in terms of the games
the games look i they just talked about
like
adding another creative lead to metroid
i don't think metroid is is anywhere
near close yeah you're close um i think
they're going to do what they did at the
launch of the switch and give us
the wild two as the show for the launch
of this upgraded console and it's gonna
sell like gangbusters and
and they're gonna you know they're gonna
keep doing what they do
yeah all right because all they have for
the rest of the year i think it's like
pikmin and then pokemon dlc and
even that and that pokemon deals people
are mad at them but honestly i mean they
had animal crossing the start of the
year
they had paper mario origami king which
they they now
a year they've announced a month before
they launched it right
um if rumors are to be believed we're
going to get some mario remasters
because it's the 35th anniversary of
mario
so there's still plenty to do
yeah they're fine they just haven't been
they haven't done a direct like we've
expected
them to do that you know and they're
focusing on the indies which again
for them still is a big selling point
because a lot of these and
coming first to switch yes right minus
four guys i was shocked
but again the fall guys falls into that
demographic where they
tend to not you know oh it's online uh
forget about it oh yeah yeah yeah
you're right you're right you're right
that makes sense now yeah
you
[Laughter]
work
yeah how many how many of those uh what
you would call it
i can now forget the what's the name of
the the squid game
oh oh
yeah i say that you know the switch did
a great job
in having third party uh games uh
high high quality games too like you
know 2k basketball
and stuff like that stuff that we never
thought we'll see on the switch
stuff that we thought nintendo was never
going to work hard at
and i thought that helped them this
generation and i don't think
uh them not pursuing 4k
they they have to uh for this next
generation because
you can't have games in this next
generation and
everybody said the witcher would not be
done should it be done that's two
different things
but it was done you understand and they
they made an effort to get it to that
demographic you know um a lot of you
guys
uh pooh-poohed the fact that you know
they were putting
these high-profile games on there but
certain people don't have a playstation
certain people
don't have an xbox but they do have a
switch and if they can play
games uh third-party titles that are
high quality
or big titles on their switch
they're happy to do so so a 4k switch
that can pursue the graphics of this
generation
cross-gen i think definitely works in
their favor
and i don't think that they're going to
throw that to the side because i think
the tegra 2 and integra 3 chips
can do it easily though nintendo was
targeting the tcl computer
i can't with john you're a mess
look i feel you okay look i hope so i
mean
you know me selfishly tech wise to see
stuff like that up friends
yeah it's just the chat right you know
so i mean look i would love the people
but i do agree with you i feel something
is cooking
i just got to see to what extent you
know what i'm saying let's get this
pulled up get up out of here new iop
poll this week oh let's get this type of
guy here um
after the recent gameplay showcase of
ratcheting like it's funny i chose this
i ripped apart at gamescom which
playstation 5 title has you
most excited for the ps5
launch window the choices are ratchet
and clank showcase that ssd
and playstation 5 next gen features king
disagrees
b spidey miles morales is
the de facto ps5 title to beat
king disagrees c either one is dead day
one
demon souls or a secret exclusive yet to
be revealed
or d i don't care all this greatness but
y'all still got craig all up in your
mouth
that is the question those are the
choices please write the vote when it
goes up on ilp
twitter salute to the realm being in
here rocking with us all these hours and
our foolishness and all the new members
salute to y'all you already know the
love so let's get lord attic going out
here we can find people find you any
more
dope videos coming sir you can find me
on twitter at lauradex
you can find me at twitter let me
introduce go get it go get it go get it
get that go go get that cold what's that
what's that
xbox code ladies and gentlemen that is
cold you don't even know
whatever the ultimate edition of one of
the great rpgs of the last two years
ac odyssey
okay get that get that you know what i'm
saying okay it's all my attitude
that's why it's always good to stay to
the end of the show stinks pop off
don't leave well i mean you know i i hit
up some in the middle of the podcast you
guys you know
guys here every week but this week in
particular it's just
uh so i want to you know throw some uh
love in that chat i always have it ready
but i get caught up in the conversation
in the super chat and i forget to drop
it and then addict had to remind me yo
drop the call
chat shout out to gabe about choice
finals some chat great show guys i have
i love the fun but y'all definitely keep
a real salute to the little salute
game about choice nobody gonna tell him
he's gonna force him to do anything
that's right he bites gaming
time time
you can find me on twitter at lord
addicts i'll feed you
you can uh yeah lord outside but you can
find me on
youtube at gaming addicts i've been
putting out videos
most likely monday i'll have my
waistline third review out
uh it's it's definitely been a um uh
a thing man it's been a long time and
you know i i wanted you know take
a moment of silence you know uh you know
for those of you that's been paying
attention
to the uh you know to twitter and stuff
we had someone in the marvel community
pass away
so you know i definitely want to give it
a moment of silence real quick to him
all right so we got a two dollar super
chat yeah the reason uh
i said that is because i meant to say at
the beginning of the podcast but i don't
know what happened
i think it was probably something it
came about first though given my choice
i got
one oh yeah yeah i got him yeah uh emery
said wakanda forever man
yeah man we with you brother yeah chad
that's why we gave him that moment of
silence you know he
he he was a fantastic actor fantastic
black panther and uh
my heart goes out to him and his family
and uh you know we'll
definitely be back next week man you
know we we gotta uh
it's nice to have just us you know
because we we could be a little bit more
loose which is uh
exactly times less the less time moments
we can rock though it's off finally
holding me down with these two dislike
lords in here
messing up the ratio
you provide balance yes that's what i
appreciate so at the time because we're
still you know we're still an xbox by
cat's apparently
apparently no we don't play anything
else
how are you gonna stand up for the other
side of your room they are keeping
i think he picks up his pizza yeah i
know what he's doing
yeah so you know what i'm doing i'm
about to go
get your pizza get off the bike
you know um yeah you know where i'm
going i'm going to work
i'm going to work but you guys can catch
me um on twitter lord south io
pbx sovereign on psn and xbox live
i will be playing more of that wasteland
when i can because
fantastic fantasy game and of course
honestly man my heart broke yesterday
when i saw this thing about chadwick
roseman man like he
uh you know earlier in the year when
people saw him really thin
you know obviously the internet is the
internet some people show concerns some
people
started memeing and i'm like this is and
i honestly hope that it was
you know there was speculation that he
was getting ready for a movie or
something like that
um i honestly hope that that was it and
apparently that was not it um
absolutely just just heartbroken because
it seemed like he was a super uh
wonderful person um and into the the
roles that he brought to life it takes a
special
person and actor to embody so many sort
of historical roles
and then somebody who can embody a
character that's never been brought to
the screen to scream before
um in a way that sort of changed the way
things are perceived in in hollywood and
so it's just a tremendous loss a
tremendous loss i feel for his family
um r.i.p yeah all right people surprise
sleeping power king
lloyd king bringing the smoke and
all the fun back to the realm as he does
we're going to five people finding
what you got going on sir um just uh to
piggyback
off of the chadwick bozeman uh
i i saw some stuff earlier this year
and um they were saying that he was on
the extreme vegan diet or something of
that nature
and like sovereignty i thought he was
getting ready for a role
and he will forever be immortalized
um he moved with the personification of
class and dignity yes even
in his uh last post and stuff like that
he paid reverence to
the uh jackie robinson and
and and uh pioneers
and i i just uh
salute the impact that he made in his
short time here yes
it's uh he is immortalized
absolutely he will forever be
a black icon and
um and someone to admire
all right so uh you can find me on
twitter the king david otw
yes sir you can find me on fridays at 9
00 p.m on
dolph castle x that's the best
uh statue show
podcast in the known universe uh
because the people there are so diverse
and we talk about so many different
topics
um we actually covered the news when it
happened
while it was happening it was a other
sad moment
um also you know get a chance to see
king of the statues there
uh so usually what happens on
thursday king of the statues go up you
can see the statue
live in the flesh if you if you want to
see it uh so to say
on our dark capsule x and then
on sunday you can see it at iop at uh
1 p.m yes sir also make sure you
make your way over to the hardest
working men in the business
lord cognito and ivantis on the last
word
oh you got it wrong though ebonitis
lord every night yesterday
i'm not even going to represent
i'm not even going to reference that but
what i would say
is i understand
you know when people have their flavor
like you know it's like a fine
restaurant and you know i saw a [ __ ] in
the other restaurant and i'm like yo
that's
nice yo you fine dining and
when he came back to his situation i was
like yeah
it may not be mr chow let's do it
oh yeah we got that comfort food we got
that
food with no condiments though you don't
do cannabis
but um yeah man uh it was always fun
us hanging out just us yes you know for
a little bit not saying that i don't
like guests love you guys but we haven't
done this in a while yeah there's always
these super chats before yeah let's get
this super chat um smitty smith
have a good day at work lord solve and
stay safe brother
thank you my brother much appreciate all
the support thank you know jw's show
prayers to his family i'm grateful to
have seen all the powerful roles he
played
god bless fellas yes recipe sleeping
power king chad bozeman man we miss you
you
man you changed the game at the end of
the day you know i'll never forget
how the entire community came together
just to go to see black panther
how the joy it brought the community to
see representation
and i mean we all shed a tear a little
bit like wow it finally happened and
proof
that it could be successful you know and
again not to minimize
all the other roles i mean he's played
so many historical roles
gracious just a good character guy
and some really cool accounts are coming
out about his story about
him doing other stuff for other cancer
victims and stuff like that and just to
think how much he suffered
while doing all these roles during that
process to have that so
salute to him forever like king said
immortalized
immortalized just a legend in the game
shout out to dm mentor for being messy
followed out of super chat and he better
not be playing sauce on the steak listen
cause you don't like condiments don't
make you
that's your business man we're putting
sauce on steak though
don't do it man cause we beat for now
we're gonna be beefing now
it's the whole time that'll go two hours
for getting me to fight with my brother
so stop it
listen last but not least man salute to
everybody in the room
tremendous week so proud of
logicgaming.net
so proud of the whole thing open credit
the team so proud of everybody
supporting iop
supporting me we're moving and grooving
we got more surprises more fun stuff
cooking
because of y'all look oh wow gamer by
choice one more
get that what's up we got a given by
choice with the five dollar super chat i
hope they can get an actor as great as
chadwick boseman for a blue
for a blue marvel role yeah i feel that
look
at the end of the day everybody enjoy
your sunday we are out of here we gonna
leave you with
king get up in that realm y'all catch
y'all later peace
hi i'm lord king david of iron lords
podcast
and we're bringing to you an exciting
new giveaway
this giveaway is like none other we'll
be giving away
a xbox series x that's right
you heard me right the brand new console
launching from microsoft this year
well this is how you're able
to be part of that giveaway there's two
ways
to get your name thrown in the hat
for the raffle one become a member
of the realm that's hit that join button
hit that joy button you hit that join
button down at the bottom
and you can become a member and also
another way is by becoming a patreon
member
so you can be part of the realm as well
now this is brought to you by cat
daddy fat stacks a member
and lord of the realm a very generous
person
that's in our community and this
community
is beautiful so remember
you can have one entry by hitting that
join button
and becoming a member of the realm and
also you can have another entry
by being a patreon now you said king
what if i'm a member of both well your
name gets thrown in the hat
two times so please
like follow and subscribe
join or become a patreon member
or become both and your name
is in the hat to get that
xbox series x
as to who did that for you sweepstakes
this is wonderful this is something that
i'm sure that you will enjoy
oh man